[Musique]
François Ruffin, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Ouais.
On vous reçoit de de On vous reçoit pour
votre activité de journaliste et
probablement de députés. Qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire sur votre travail
de journaliste et de députés ?
D'abord, moi je sépare pas les deux. Je
me considère comme étant député
reporter.
pour plusieurs raisons. D'abord, je je
pense que depuis des années, en fait,
depuis une vingtaine d'années, je fais
un travail qui est un travail
d'expression. Expression du verbe
exprimer. Exprimer, c'est un verbe que
j'adore parce que ça veut dire pousser
dehors. Donc c'est
animateur de la démocratie.
Animateur de la démocratie. si tu vas
pousser dehors. Ce que tu as dans le
bid, tu le pousses. Bon et donc ça
aurait pu il y a 20 ans tomber sur déjà
de la politique euh de la parole
publique. Enfin, il me fallait j'avais
un besoin de parole publique et bah à
l'époque ça s'est canalisé sur un le
journalisme et donc sur la création d'un
journal. Mais ça aurait pu être du
cinéma, ça aurait pu être du théâtre, ça
aurait pu être euh du de la politique
directement. C'est ce que j'avais, c'est
un besoin d'expression, de pousser
dehors ce que j'avais dans le ventre. Et
puis la deuxième chose, je pense c'est
un autre verbe, c'est représenter. Je
pense que ça fait 20 ans que j'essaie de
représenter les gens, c'està-dire les
représenter dans un journal, par exemple
des contre en prolarité, des
intérimires, des gens qui sont en
hôpitaux psychiatrique, de leur donner
un visage de rapporter leurs propos, de
parler avec eux pour eux et tout ça. Et
donc je l'ai fait d'abord dans un
journal, ensuite je l'ai fait à la
radio. Je faisais parler dans les
émissions de radio de Daniel Mermé à la
base si j'y suis. Ensuite, j'ai fait un
film euh merci patron mais où c'est
toujours pareil, je représentais, il y
avait des gens du peuple qui étaient
représentés à l'écran et c'est pas
toujours fréquent et aujourd'hui,
j'essaie d'être de toujours représenter
ces gens comme représentant puisque
c'est le titre qui est le mien, voilà,
représentant de la nation. Donc euh je
pense qu'en fait il y a une je moi je
vois plus une continuité euh entre ce
que je fais depuis 20 ans à Fakir et ce
que je fais aujourd'hui comme député euh
que une rupture. Pour moi, il y a une
vraie continuité entre tout ça.
Alors notre chaîne internet est
spécialisée sur la géopolitique, la
finance, le terrorisme et le hacking.
Vous voulez qu'on commence par quoi ?
Je vais te dire franchement il y aon la
finance si ça peut largement m'inspirer
euh mais pour les autres thèmes souvent
je disais euh bon moi déjà quand on
quand on va en Champagne Arden tu vois
je suis quand même picard j'étais élu
sous la sous la bannière Picardie debout
donc déjà quand je vais en champagne
d'de c'est la politique étrangère tu
vois laorine c'est l'Afghanistan pour
moi. Donc maintenant, bon, je suis
représentant de la nation et pas
seulement la première circonscription de
la Somme, mais enfin vraiment les
questions internationales. D'ailleurs,
tu sais, j'ai j'ai beaucoup j'ai écrit
pas mal le papier pour le monde diplôme
pour le monde diplomatique et il y avait
toujours des gens même en école de
journaliste d'ailleurs qui voulaient
aller un peu partout dans le monde et
moi je considérais que là où il y avait
besoin d'être et là où il y avait moins
de journalistes qui avaient envie
d'être, bah c'était à Flix secours,
c'était à Forest en Cambrésie, c'était
enfin c'était près de chez moi quoi. Et
donc je fait le choix de en effet ne pas
aller faire quatre fois le tour du
monde. Je dis pas que ça ça présente pas
un intérêt et qu'il faille pas le faire
mais c'est vrai que je pense qu'il y
avait une pente naturelle de ce côté-là.
Et au monde diplô j'ai sur des je disais
il y avait pas forcément beaucoup de
monde qui restait en France pour étudier
le logement pour étudier la marine marge
française ou des thèmes comme cela. Donc
je comme pigiste hein, pas comme salarié
du monde diplô mais je faisais plutôt ça
mien et je j'ai toujours dit que je je
traitais ces dossier là dans Fakir, les
dossiers de social et d'économie
français et que je déléguais tout ce qui
était politique internationale au monde
diplomatique. C'était un peu notre
sous-traitant quoi.
Bon on va voir ce que vous avez sous le
coffre.
Oh
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire par exemple
sur l'Italie en ce moment ?
Oh là là là là franchement tu as décidé
de m'interroger sur tous les sujets où
je suis pas où je vais pas être bon.
C'est ça ? Les sujets où tu es bon,
c'est après.
D'accord.
Sur l'Italie,
euh tu vois la question que j'ai eu par
un journaliste italien, c'est bon bah
est-ce que la France insoumise et Marine
Le Pen, ils vont faire la même chose ?
Tu vois, en gros
5 étoiles 5 que 5 étoiles et puis la
Ligue du Nord, quoi. Donc bon, pour moi,
c'est exclu et en fait, il se passera
pas ce qui se passe en Italie parce
qu'il y a la France insoumise.
C'est-à-dire que il reste aujourd'hui
quelque chose à gauche en France,
quelque chose qui est pas moléculaire,
qui concentre des forces. Tandis qu'en
Italie à gauche, il ne reste plus rien.
Tout a été explosé. Donc il y a ça. Donc
par quoi
tout a été explosé ? parce que
l'histoire de je pense de la gauche
italienne est pas la même que la nôtre.
Ils se sont complètement dissolus dans
mais ce ceci ça aurait pu arriver en
France et ça n'est pas arrivé
heureusement quoi. Euh donc il reste
aujourd'hui deux voix d'expression à la
colère populaire.
Moi ça a été mon combat pendant les
législatives dans la Somme. Et tu vois
comment de la Picardie je reviens à la
Somme parce que j'y suis plus à l'aise.
Mais ça été tout mon combat ça a été
comment faire pour que une colère se
canalise chez moi plutôt qu'au Front
National. C'était une vraie bagarre. Tu
vois, ce matin, j'étais sur le parking
de l'usine Wepool à Amien euh parce que
c'était le le jour de la fermeture. Et
euh
en ce jour de fermeture où hier mais euh
la direction de Whpool a convainqué un
comité extraordinaire,
un CE extraordinaire pour dire que ils
avaient besoin de salariés pour aller en
Pologne installer les machines. Tu
imagines la violence du truc ? Tu
imagines le degré de mépris pour les
salariés dont on a décidé de
licenciement et dont le dernier jour de
travail, on vient leur dire bah on vous
propose euh d'aller vous-même euh et il
ce que me dit le délégué syndical CFDT
Frédéric Chantrel et je pense qu'il a
raison, c'est que le pire c'est qu'il y
a des gens qui vont aller le faire parce
qu'il y a des gens qui ont faim enfin
faim parce qu'il y a des gens qui
c'est de la soumission qu'on sentit. Ben
ouais, il y a une surtout c'est de la
résignation,
c'est de la résignation,
tu vois. On est dans aujourd'hui dans un
degré de résignation, c'est le pire.
Moi, je disais toujours pendant ma
campagne, mon adversaire, c'est la
finance, mais c'est surtout
l'indifférence. Et c'est le pire qu'on a
à combattre, c'est ce dégré ce degré de
résignation. Comment faire pour que les
gens
se réveillent quoi ? Et c'est le la
grosse bagarre qu'on a amené. Tu sais
ça, je cite souvent une phrase de Samuel
Huntington, donc l'auteur du choc des
civilisation qui est un auteur bien à
droite, un ultralibéral américain et
avant le choc des civilisation dans en
1975, il rédige un rapport pour la
commission trilatérale.
On connaît très bien la commission
trilatérale.
Voilà. Donc qui réunit, mais je le dis
quand même pour vos internautes, qui
réunit euh les élites américaines,
européennes et japonaises
asiatiques.
Ouais. Et pour ce euh
pour ce document, il écrit qui est donc
consacré à la démocratie. Il écrit "Le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui, c'est que
les problèmes
créer de l'apathie politique."
Voilà, les les peuples ont tendance à se
prendre au sérieux. C'est un risque, ils
prennent la démocratie au sérieux. Or,
si les peuples prennent la démocratie au
sérieux, les élites ne peuvent pas gérer
les pays correctement. Donc ce qu'il
faut installer dans les pays, c'est une
bonne dose d'apathie politique. C'est
écrit comme ça dans son document. Et euh
en effet, depuis les années 70, on voit
que l'apatie copolitique euh qui
prennent le nom de résignation,
d'abstention, d'indifférence au destin
commun, euh de sentiment de plus pouvoir
rien faire sur notre sort à tous, on
voit que ça ça a considérablement
augmenté et que c'est le grand
adversaire, tu vois. Mais donc je
reviens à mon truc de whol. Euh la
question c'est euh euh pour ces gens-là
euh tu vois euh de même Macron est passé
dans l'usine en le 3 octobre dernier et
avec le patron qui reprend et il a
assuré que tous les salariés seraient
repris. Il y a une vingtaine de salariés
qui sont sur le carreau. C'est des
grandes gueules. C'est mec qui ont fait
une grève. C'est des mecs qui
est- que c'est des mecs qui comprennent
la guerre économique ?
Mon travail est un travail, je dirais
pas de pédagogie mais de quand s'il y a
quelque chose qui leur tombe sur la
tronche, vaguement ils savent ce que
c'est. Mais tu vois le risque quand tu
arrives sur le parking de Whpool c'est
tu le vois d'ailleurs quand je suis allé
distribuer les tracks, le fondation
était passé avant moi. Mais c'est c'est
la faute aux réfugiés, c'est la faute
aux assistés.
On va venir sur ce sur ce sujet là. Et
donc la bagarre, c'est comment faire
pour que ils se disent pas ça. Et donc
c'est vrai que moi j'arrive en montrant
euh en leur demandant s'ils savent qui
est Jeff Fatig, PDG de WHpool, ils
ignorent le nom jusqu'au nom de leur
PDG. Vuard Group, tu vois, c'est le
groupe, il me semble, qui détient aussi
des bonnes parts dans Monstau. Ils
ignorent qui est V Guard Group, le fond
de pension. Ben, c'est apporter ces
éléments-l. Moi c'est c'est vrai que je
ramène la baraque la photo de la baraque
du PDG de Jeff Fétig parce que il y a 80
changes bon parce que il y a 20 salles
de bain parce qu'il y a un cours de
tennis parce qu'il y a une piscine
souterraine parce qu'il y a un accès
direct à la plage et parce que s'ils
avaient ça en sortant de leur usine ils
se diraient mon adversaire c'est Jeff
Fatig c'est évident comme la baraque
elle est pas là mais elle a 5672 km je
sais plus exactement mais j'avais
vérifié sur les trucs Mapi la distance
entre Amien et je sais plus quelle ville
tu vois et Et ben comme a cette distance
géographique, ça produit aussi une
distance affective et du coup ils se
disent pas du tout c'est la fête faute
de ce mec là, ils vont on va les ramener
à c'est de la faute à l'assisté qui
parce qu'il y a toujours un assisté dans
dans son quartier. C'est évident. Enfin
quelqu'un on voit il travaille pas, il
est tellement découragé, il y a plein de
raisons mais il peut y avoir ça. Et ou
alors c'est de la faute au réfugié parce
que lui on le voit à la télé. Et donc
comment tu dépasses ce ce truc de ce
qu'on voit ce qu'on a de côté de chez
soi à l'adversaire est invisible ? Mais
tu vois, ça y est, je pars en live.
D'accord.
Bientôt je vais te mettre un gros stop.
Bon euh mardi soir, on est dans
l'hémicycle, tu vois. Je passe de du
reporter que j'étais ce matin, mais
toujours député qui vient discuter avec
les gens. Et le fait que les gens me
voient sur le parking, bah ça ça fait
que leur colère euh ils se disent qu'il
y a un mec pour la porter, tu vois. Et
est-ce que tu es est-ce que tu es pas
euh
l'idiot utile dans ce combat là ?
Vas-y, précise.
Est-ce que le fait de canaliser leur
colère ne les anesthésie pas ?
Je crois pas du tout. Tu sais, ça fait
30 ans que de toute façon
fait l'avocat du diable.
Ouais, mais oui, mais il y a pas de
problème. Je
Mais je crois pas du tout. Je tu sais
quand j'étais
est-ce que la vindicte populaire tel le
vent sauvage ne doit pas se manifester
comme un feu d'un feu de cheminée ou un
feu dans dans les champs ?
Moi je crois pas que ça se je crois pas
queil y ait de truc la la spontanéité
des masses. J'y crois pas trop. Tu vois
pourquoi ? parce que je vois trop queil
y a la résignation qui s'installe et que
du coup euh derrière c'est plutôt chacun
se replie dans son coin. Euh et euh tu
vois si nous avons eu notre rôle pour
organiser le fait qu'il y ait simplement
une grève chez Whpool parce que le gros
risque l'année dernière, je te je reste
sur ce cas-là, le risque l'année
dernière c'est que on leur annonce du
jour au lendemain que leur usine elle va
être délocalisée.
On leur a déjà fait le coup sur le
lave-linge en 2002. On leur a demandé
des tas de sacrifices de venir bosser le
weekend, de pas être rémunéré au tarif
normal, enfin des tas de trucs. Ils ont
accepté tout ça. On leur annonce quand
même que ça va partir en Pologne. Et il
y avait il y a eu des semaines sans
grève, il y a eu des semaines sans
mouvement social où au contraire les
gens se bouffaient la gueule les uns les
autres
et où on on se déchirait avec les
syndicats et nous avons pas
explique ça c'est un manque de
communication c'est un manque d'empathie
ou c'est simplement un manque de
conscience intellectuelle dans la
gestion de la crise ?
Je crois que le le degré de désarrois
des de ceux qui sont confrontés à ça euh
et qui sont qui sont confrontés de
manière répétitive quand dans la même
ville tu as eu WHpool, tu as eu
Magimarelli, tu as eu une Hwell, tu as
eu Flow d'or un petit peu plus loin, tu
as eu leurs parents qui ont eu le le la
délocalisation de toutes les usines
textiles dans la vallée de la Nièvre. tu
as une le découragement
des gens, il est puissant et donc euh
aller contre ça et se dire qu'on peut
encore quelque chose alors que les
gouilleurs se sont battus, ils ont
perdu, ils ont été condamnés, moi je
pense qu'ils ont gagné quand même plein
de choses que le plan social aurait été
bien pire et tout ça mais enfin tu vois
et que tu as les médias mais pas
seulement, tu as un certain nombre de
gens qui disent grosso modo, ils
auraient mieux fait de pas se battre
parce que du coup ils sont marqués au
fer rouge, il y a pas eu de repreneur,
il y a pas eu tout ça donc il vaut mieux
ne pas bouger, tu vois. Tu as tout un
truc comme ça.
Il vaut mieux pas se sacrifier dans ces
cas-là.
Se sacrifier à quoi ?
Je sais pas. On a vu des manifestations
avec des gars qui étaient assis sur des
bouteilles de gaz et qui menaçaient de
tout faire péter.
Bah tu vois c'est mais ça c'est pas se
sacrifier, c'est une autre forme de
lutte.
C'est pas sacrifier ça.
Non parce qu'ils les ont pas fait péter
les bouteilles de gaz.
Il étaient prêt.
Tout mois tout comme chez c'est latex tu
vois. J'ai j'ai adoré le bouquin quand
l'acide a failli couler ou un truc comme
ça qui est un bouquin qui a été rédigé
par l'un des dirigeants de la CGT
textile sur l'usine Catex. euh en
dans les Ardenes où ils ont failli
mettre de l'acide à la rivière. Bon, moi
c'est pas quelque chose que je
recommande du tout, mais il y avait c
menace d'un d'un crime environnemental
quelque chose quelque part, mais
c'était un mauvais objectif.
Euh bon, c'était un bon moyen et
heureusement, il n'est pas arrivé à la
fin n'a pas été utilisée et je pense
qu'il y avait pas grand monde qui
voulait queon en arrive là, quoi. Mais
quand l'acide a coulé, c'est le titre.
Mais donc voilà, mais mais je c'est un
bouquin qui est vraiment pour comprendre
ce qui se passe dans une lutte. C'est un
bouquin clé, y compris on peut avoir une
distance critique vis-à-vis que de ce
que raconte le mec parce que Christian
Larose, on voit à travers le bouquin que
son objectif est moins que parfois que
les salariés obtiennent vraiment
satisfaction que d'avoir un mode de
négociation. Chacun a un mode de
négociation avec l'étape du dus. C'est
vraiment un jeu tactique et lui son
objectif c'est que la CGT s'en sorte pas
trop mal. C'est-à-dire que les salariés,
bon, ils ils aient quelque chose mais en
même temps que le le logo CGT, il soit
pas entaché par un crime
environnemental, quoi. Donc tu as des
espèces de négociation comme ça en
série. Mais pourquoi je parle de ça ?
Euh tu La question c'était quoi ?
L'Italie.
Ah l'Italie. Bon ben voilà,
je pense que on a la on n'est pas dans
la situation italienne parce que
aujourd'hui il y a encore la possibilité
que ça passe par la gauche. Je veux dire
que le jour où le le gros centre formé
par Macron
s'écroulera éventuellement, je fais pas
de paris sur l'avenir, mais si jamais il
s'écroule et ben il y aura une autre
réponse possible que le Front National.
OK. La Libye,
c'est quoi le pays d'après ?
L'Afghanistan.
Non non, l'Afghanistan
non franchement tu tu m'amènes tu
m'amènes sur des sujets sur surqu je
pourrais renc raconter des trucs mais
mais pas terrible du tout. Donc je
préfère mais
dis non, je vais à question pour un
champion, je vais perdre à tous les
coups. Bon bah t'inquiète c'est que le
début.
Ça fait ça te fait penser à quoi la Libi
? Ah non, bah ça me fait pas penser aux
histoires de Kaddafi de Tu vois la
Libye.
Alors, une question d'internet histoire
de te chauffer un peu les neurones.
Comment peut-on comment peut-on gérer
les problèmes de la France sans
s'intéresser à la politique
internationale ?
Je pense que
pim.
Ouais. Non mais
d'abord
chacun est limité dans le dans le tu
vois à un moment de son ce Moi je me
présente pas un homme d'état
aujourd'hui.
Ça tu l'as déjà dit chez Bourdin ?
Ouais. Ben je te le redis mais parce que
c'est la vérité tu vois et pu ça prouve
que je tiens pas un dial un discours
différent chez Bourdin de chez
Finkerview mais je me considère pas
comme un homme d'état aujourd'hui. Il
faut m'utiliser à autre chose. Je suis
pas un bon animateur de la démocratie.
La Libye ça te fait penser à quoi ?
Est-ce que c'est un scandale d'État ?
Est-ce que c'était nécessaire en tant
que citoyen, ça te fait penser à quoi ?
De quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui était nécessaire
? L'intervention en Libye.
Non, moi je Comment elle s'appelait la
ville ? Je me souviens plus.
Euh Tobrook. Non non,
la ville qu'on a on devait sauver une
ville. Ah mince.
Tu te souviens plus en Libye, le début
de l'opération en Libye,
on a commencé à sauver beaucoup de
villes pour la Libye, il y avait une
ville en particulier. Vous pouvez pas
chercher sur internet en même temps.
La communauté va s'en chercher.
Donc vous allez voir, ça tient en 2
secondes. Mais le point de départ de la
Libye, c'est qu'on nous demande de
sauver une ville qui est
particulièrement qui se soulève un peu
et qui est euh attaqué par Kaddafi. Vous
l'avez le nom ou pas ?
Ça va venir, t'inquiète. continue.
Bon et c'est incroyable que ça
m'échappe. Il y a tout un débat sur
est-ce qu'il faut y aller, pas y aller,
l'ONU, tout ça. Et je suis très partagé
à l'époque. Je suis pas un mec, tu vois.
D'abord sur des histoires que je connais
pas
partagé. Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? Parce que d'un côté, on te
dit bien que ils s' ils s'en prennent
plein la gueule par Kaddafi, il y a pas
de doute.
Ce qui était des mythos
et hein
ce qui était des mythos, l'aviation n'a
pas bombardé.
Voilà. Et ensuite parce que tu dis bon
bah on s'est déjà fait avoir quoi quand
même. Bon,
Bazzi. Benzi, exact, c'est ça. Benzi,
faut-il sauver Bengazi ? Et donc, je
vais te dire franchement à l'époque, je
suis plutôt pour y aller pour sauver
Bengazi quoi. Et mais je le dis
mollement, tu vois, c'est le genre de
truc où je d'abord je fais pas de machin
sur les R.
Tu es réceptif à la propagande de
guerre.
Euh, sur ce tru là, j'y ai pas été
complètement indifférent en tout cas. Et
donc je j'y suis plutôt et après tout de
suite après tu vois tu vois comment de
Benazi il passe à Tripoli et là je me
sens cocu.
Je me suis fait avoir et je pense que
plein de monde s'est fait avoir et les
Russes se sont fait avoir et je pense
qu'on peut pas comprendre ce qui s'est
passé sur la Syrie si on comprend pas
la Libye
Oui mais je te dis
d'accord sur la Syrie ensuite. OK, on
peut pas comprendre ce qui se passe sur
la Syrie aujourd'hui si on n pas compris
ce qui s'est passé sur la Libye.
C'està-dire la manière dont les forces
occidentales en l'occurrence
ont fait cocu moi mais aussi la Russie.
Euh je dis pas que je suis pour la
position de la Russie sur la Syrie.
J'imagine que la conction d'après, c'est
la Syrie. [__] disons euh je en plus
je suis pas la commission des affaires
internationales ni de la défense à à pas
mon problème
à l'Assemblée nationale,
mais je on peut pas comprendre euh ce
qui ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en Syrie
si on comprend pas la manière dont on a
été cocu en Libye. Et je pense que Bazi
a un gros rôle là-dedans. C'est-à-dire
qu'on donne un chèque en disant "OK,
allez sauver Bengazi" et puis finalement
ils vont virer Kaddafi de Tripoli et
donc et tu installes tu installes un
gros bordel là-bas. C'est pas qu'on soit
copain avec Kadfille, on n pas reçu de
pognon de Kadfille mais donc voilà et
donc
voilà et donc aujourd'hui bah c'est sûr
que quand on Syrie on commence à dire
"Bon benah il va falloir comenc aller
intervenir pour sauver une ville ou pour
défendre machin". Ben moi je je suis
plus qu'hésitant et tu vois comment les
Russes ils sont hésitants aussi quoi.
Donc la Syrie c'est bon on a déjà
éclusé. Voilà, c'est bien.
Il y a la Russie. Donc on va parler de
la Russie.
Tu as lancé le truc
? Non, c'est fait. La Russie
Poutine, qu'est-ce fait [__] dis tu as
vraiment que ça ? Mais c'est tuas
vraiment pas spécial préliminaire,
tu sais. Est-ce que je vais être
beaucoup bien meilleur sur le vimeux ?
Tu sais où c'est le vimeux ?
Allez, la Russie.
Non, j'ai rien à dire.
Non, du tout.
Non, je crois pas. Non.
L'affaire scripale,
j'ai rien à dire.
Ça te fait penser sur la à quoi ?
L'affaire scripale ?
Rien du tout.
Rien
du tout.
Non. un gaz neurotoxique.
[__] ! Et vraiment les internautes,
ils vont dire il est nul celui-là, il
aurait mieux faire.
On va faire plus simple. On va faire
plus simple. Donald Trump.
Ouais.
Tu sais
les sanctions les sanctions sur la
Russie, par les États-Unis, par l'Union
européenne, les sanctions économiques.
Je vais dire un autre truc parce que bon
ma bagarre euh c'est euh de faire que
les gens ils existent. Je Non mais ouais
mais ouais mais ouais mais je vais c'est
tout et c'est mon mon combat
journalistique depuis 20 ans, tu vois.
Euh c'est-à-dire que tu as l'impression
que l'actualité euh les news c'est la
vie et les faits des grands hommes et
que en fond ça a pas tellement changé
depuis l'historiographie du Moyen-Âge
que c'est Macron que ça peut même être
Mélenchon, que c'est tu vois les hommes
politiques locaux et puis les grands
hommes politiques internationaux. Et moi
ma bagère c'est quoi ? c'est de venir
ramener autre chose. C'est de venir
ramener bah tu vois
ça que tu es avec la France assoumise
ça peut être un motif mais je veux dire
c'est pour ça que c'est ce qui en tout
cas indépendamment de l'étiquette que je
porte aujourd'hui c'est ce qui m'anime
depuis 20 ans et je pourrais être sans
étiquette aujourd'hui.
Le Venezu est là.
Oh là là
non
non mais tu vois je préfère parler. Il y
a un mec que je connaissais pas son nom
mais il travaillait chez Carbon Laoren
et je l'ai croisé juste après WH Pool.
Je suis allé à la Confédération paysane.
On y va. On y va. On y va. Il y avait
l'Angleterre. Non, l'Union européenne.
L'Union européenne du connais.
Ouais. Bon, d'accord. Bah l'Union
européenne, oui, ça m'inpire davantage.
On est plus proche de
Bon, alors l'Union européenne, qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire dessus ?
Là, on pourrait en parler pendant
longtemps. En revanche,
bah ça tombe bien, on a du temps.
L'Union européenne, tu vois là je sors
du projet de loi agriculture. Je voulais
instaurer des prix planchés. Donc
le lait,
voilà le lait, je crois que c'est 40
centimes d'euros. Je voulais instaurer
un prix minimal aussi pour le port, un
prix minimal pour le blé. Les paysans
quand ils vont vendre à leur
coopérative, quand ils vont vendre à
l'industrie agroalimentaire,
Ricardo, ça te parle
qui ?
Ricardo ?
Ah oui, ça me parle mais oui, mais tu
sais, j'ai écrit un bouquin sur
protectionnisme. Dis, tu interrompement,
tu interromps plus que Bourdin, tu sais.
Euh
Bin, il est moins bon que moi.
Mais mais euh donc voilà, je voulais
instaurer un prix minimal pour que les
paysans ils un revenu garanti. Bon euh
on me dit c'est pas possible parce qu'il
y a Bruxelles. Euh hier en commission
des affaires économiques, il y a un
rapport sur les barrages. On demande la
privatisation des barrages. Qui demande
ça ? Bruxelles. Sur le rail. Qui demande
la privatisation du rail ou la mise en
concurrence ? pardon Bruxelles sur je me
suis opposé à la loi sur le secret des
affaires. Je suis longtemps intervenu
là-dessus. Pourquoi il faut faire une
loi sur le secret des affaires Bruxelles
? Donc c'est sûr que quotidiennement tu
vois l'influence de l'Union européenne,
c'est pas l'influence d'ailleurs. Et
autant quand j'étais simple citoyen et
pas simple, il y a pas de raison qu'on
soit simple, mais enfin quand j'étais
citoyen engagé, euh je le savais
théoriquement.
Mais c'est pas un truc que tu mesures et
là c'est un truc que je mesure toutes
les semaines euh le l'imposition par
l'Union européenne quoi. Dont on est
partie prenante, il faut le dire aussi.
Mais enfin c'est un truc que toutes les
semaines, tu vois les mesures qui
tombent et là on est dans la semaine du
29 mai 2005 quand même de cet
anniversaire.
Et moi, c'est une date importante. C'est
une date important.
Dit chez Bourdin
hein.
Ce que tu as dit chez Bourdin ? J'ai
déjà dit Chez Brodin. [__] mais disons
je on a parlé de ça chez Brodin.
Est-ce qu'on en sort de l'Union
européenne ?
Moi aujourd'hui je suis pour la
désobéissance.
De toute façon, sortir de l'Union de
l'Union européenne, ça veut dire sortir
des traités. L'Union européenne n'est
qu'une somme de traités. Bon euh moi, je
suis aujourd'hui pour la désobéissance.
Euh c'est-à-dire que
prendre des prunes et attendre que ça se
passe
quoi. Bah je pense que il y a moyen
d'instaurer un bras de fer et qu'on sera
pas tout seul à l'instaurer. Mais je
pense qu'il faut il faut instaurer un
bras de faire sur les barrages. Tu
refuses de privatiser les barrages et tu
leur dis tu vois même c'était une
députée socialiste qui présentait le
rapport et je lui demandé est-ce que
vous êtes alors est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à la désobéissance ? Elle a
tricoté pendant 3 minutes mais à la fin
elle a dit oui. Et je pense que il y a
un certain nombre de projets de loi
comme ça sur lequel moi je les aurais
instauré les prix planchés. Il y a
d'autres trucs que j'aurais instauré et
derrière bras de fer. Bras de fer.
Pourquoi ? Il y a une raison euh
c'est comment tu entraînes les gens avec
toi. Et si tu leur montres sur plein de
choses que ça bloque, tu peux pas mener
la politique que tu veux, que tu peux
pas mener les redistributions que tu
veux parce que l'Union européenne
t'impose une doxa, peu à peu, tu
conquières les gens. Mais aujourd'hui,
moi je suis pas sûr d'être mur pour une
sortie franche de tous les traités
européens et je je suis absolument
convaincu que le corps social n'y est
français n'y est pas prêt.
La France insoumise
euh
je pense pas que ça soit ça qui ça qui
soit aujourd'hui. Tu sais, ils sont sur
un truc plan A, plan B. Ils sont nous
sommes
sur j'ai sur un truc plan B avec si ça
marche pas en étant élu et en
renégociant les en demandant une
renégociation des traités et bien nous
mettrons en place le plan B c'est-à-dire
une sortie de l'Union européenne. Moi je
je je pense que l'axe de la
désobéissance est un axe intéressant et
je serai pour un axe de désobéissance
régulière, c'està-dire de faire un
certain nombre de propositions et de
projets de loi qui cadr pas avec ce que
demande l'Union européenne et soit
l'Union européenne va constamment au
bras de fer et on montre que c'est
impossible de mener une politique pour
l'égalité.
D'accord. D'accord. D'accord. Donc ton
bras de fer, OK, quand tu as un bras de
fer, tu compares le bras de ton copain
quand même.
D'accord. Qu'est-ce que tu as en face
avec tes petits bras ? Tu vas arrêter de
cotiser, tu vas arrêter de payer, tu vas
arrêter de payer tes prunes ? Qu'est-ce
que tu vas faire ? Parce que tu sais, si
tu respectes pas les directives
européennes, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Tu
te prends des amendes.
Tu prends les amendes, tu peux choisir
de pas les payer. Puis c'est tout les
amendes, hein. Donc
comme ça.
Bah oui, comme ça.
D'accord.
Tu vois, je ce sera pas la première fois
qu'on paye pas une prune. Non,
tu sais pas un peu brasser du vent ça ?
Je crois pas. Je crois je je je si je te
le dis, c'est parce que je crois que
c'est le chemin et euh je pense que si
tu montres ça euh aujourd'hui, c'est pas
comme si on était sur une situation
stable au niveau de l'Union européenne.
Tu veux récupérer un chemin
souverainiste ?
En tout cas, la souveraineté populaire
pour moi, elle fait aucun doute que
c'est au que c'est au peuple de décider
et au peuple français. Je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la politique, elle se
décide encore essentiellement au niveau
national. Quand tu vois en Italie que
les huiles de l'Union européenne lui
disent "Les marchés financiers vont
apprendre au peuple à bien voter,
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ta tête
quand tu entends ça ?"
Ben, tu vois, la limite le le bras de
fer le plus compliqué du coup, il est
pas franchement avec Bruxelles, mais il
est directement avec les marchés
financiers. Et tu vois, on quand on
quand j'avais j'avais interrogé un
financier juste avant l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Hollande,
qui ça ?
Oh merde, un mec de chevreux, ça dit
quelque chose ? Nicolas Doisi qui était
le chief économiste de Chevreux, ça me
revient. Et c'était vachement
intéressant parce que tu sais la langue
de la finance, elle est passionnante
parce que les mecs qui écrivent noir sur
blanc euh ce qui est souvent baratiné,
baragouiné, habillé euh enfin c'est du
déguisement ce qui est produit au
dehors. Et là tu avais le truc cache
quoi. Euh soit Hollande de toute façon,
on a confiance, il va se plier au marché
mais s'il se plie pas au marché, voilà
ce qu'on lui mettra dans la gueule.
Alors là, le seul problème c'est il me
disait c'est le seul problème qu'on a
vu, c'est euh la pression Mélenchon.
Enfin parce qu'il y avait une manife de
Mélenchon la semaine d'avant. Donc c'est
le seul moment où il a eu un regard qui
se tournait vers la fenêtre à
l'extérieur, c'est-à-dire cette pression
du de de ce qui peut venir de la rue. De
toute façon, moi ce que je ce dont je
suis convaincu,
c'est que rien ne sera possible si
jamais il y a pas une pression populaire
qui est dingue quoi.
Comment tu veux avoir une pression
populaire avec une masse décérébrée qui
n'arrive pas à se fédérer, à se
coaliser, à s'organiser et à
synchroniser ?
Je refuse le terme des des cérébrés.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais je refuse le le terme
décérébré. Euh on le niveau éducatif euh
français, il est élevé et euh le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui,
tu te bases sur quel chiffre ?
Bah je veux dire, tu sais auparavant
c'est comme quand on dit euh qui n'ont
pas de compétence ou qui ne sont pas
qualifiés, les salariés qui ne sont pas
qualifiés, mais il y a il y a un siècle
où un peu plus quand quelqu'un savait
lire et écrire, il était déjà qualifié.
Donc on a des gens qui sont qualifiés.
Mais si on a le le les
on a des analpha web
quoi.
On a des analpha web.
Oui. Bon pas peut-être mais bon tu vois
le degré de connexion des gens il est
important. Puis c'est pas c'est pas
là-dessus que je que la politique elle
se passe pas non plus que sur internet
même si vous y êtes, quoi. Donc même si
moi je te le disais, je remercie Marc
Juckerberg tous les jours
parce que c'est un bon moyen quand même
de contourner les médias. Mais donc
peut-être que c'est un thème d'après qui
m'inspirera davantage. Non, tu l'as pas
noté sur ta feuille, tu peux le
rajouter. J'ai
j'ai pire que ça.
Euh mais non, tu sais en
est-ce que les masses populaires
Oui, oui, j'ai compris.
OK, continue.
Euh en 36, quelques mois avant le Front
populaire, les gens sont d'un niveau de
découragement et de désespérance qui
semble atteindre des sommets quoi. Je
sais pas si tu as lu, c'est pas Simon
Veale, pas avec un W, la philosophe à la
fois chrétienne et communiste et qui
décrit travaillant me semble-t-il à
Boulogne Bill en cours chez Renault mais
je peux me tromper qui décrit le decret
de découragement, d'apathie politique,
d'indifférence des salariés et en
quelques semaines ou en quelques mois ça
se transforme. Mais tu vois, regarde
puisque je parlais de 2005, tu avais
connu cette période ou pas ? 2005 avec
les services de santé dans la rue et
dans C 98 tu as 2005 c'était le
référendum sur le traité constit
quel beau moment politique
magnifique non mais attends les gens il
parlaient d'un traité il parlaient de ce
qu'il y avait dans un traité
constitutionnel européen et là il y
avait de la politique parce que c'était
pas juste pour quel bonhomme on va voter
tu vois c'était pas une icône. C'était
oui ou non. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait l'Union
européenne ? Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
la libre circulation des capitaux et des
marchandises y compris avec les pays
tiers ? Je rajoute toujours avec je
n'oublions pas le y compris avec les
pays tiers. C'estàd pas seulement au
sein de l'Union européenne mais avec
ailleurs. Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
concurrence libre et non faussée ? Et tu
avais moi j'étais reporter pour Daniel
Mermé à l'émission Labas si j'y suis à
l'époque tu avais cette discussion là
partout tu allais à la porte des usines
tu avais cette discussion là tu allais
chez les gens
la veille de 36 là
aujourd'hui non enfin je pense pas je je
je non non je crois pas d'abord avant 36
il y avait eu des trucs qui qui
sentaient bon il y avait eu d'abord le
début de 36 c'est 34 l'un de mes héros
c'est Maurice Cgal Valrimont tu connais
ou pas ? Non non, Maurice Cel Valmon,
c'est un haut dirigeant de la résistance
française. C'est celui qui a fait
prisonnier le général VCHIT à la
libération, donc le commandant du Gross
Paris et qui voilà donc un très haut
dirigeant de la résistance française et
il me raconte 1934, donc le moment où
les fascistes
manifestent devant l'Assemblée et sont
au bord de faire tomber la 3e
République. qui me dit "Bon, à ce
moment-là, on se mobilise contre les
fascistes, contre pour une République
qui pourtant elle est elle est pourrie,
elle est vérôée. Et si j'avais dit à mes
copains dans les manifes à ce moment-là,
dans 2 ans, il y aura les Fronts
populaires, on aura les congés payés et
on aura les 40 heures, il m'aurait
rionné."
OK. Tout tout ça, ça s'est basé sur quel
système ? sur une augmentation de
consommation énergétique.
Je on peut pas ramener ce qui s'est
passé au niveau du Front populaire qui
est quand même un
la constatation c'est une augmentation
du consommation énergétique.
Non mais de toute façon les gens ils
allaient à la mer en vélo donc tu vois
ça va c'est limité. Tu vois c'était pas
la c'était pas l'usage de la bagnole en
1900 en 1936 donc par exemple
accès à la protéine plus facilement une
meilleure alimentation. H
bah oui bah dans le problème alors tu
vois par exemple si on parle de ça le
problème c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
une fois qu'on a été autant
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir le faire
disons disons franchement tu te rends
compte que j'ai même pas le temps de
faire deux phrases
compte que tu parles beaucoup
Ah bon par rapport aux autres ? J'ai pas
l'impression moi.
Qu'est-ce que Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir le
faire là
à qui ?
À nous est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
renégocier des acquis sociaux ? Est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir défendre les acquis
qu'on a déjà eu ? Ben je je pense qu'en
tout cas on a une marge de malovre, tu
vois. Je je toujours euh dans le en
1983,
on était euh à 4 % de la valeur ajoutée
euh qui euh qui partait en en dividende.
Aujourd'hui, on est à 12 %. Ça veut dire
que grosso modo, les salariés français
en 1983 laissaient une semaine de
salaire en en dividende et aujourd'hui
il en laisse trois. Donc déjà, ne
serait-ce que là-dessus, il y a du grain
à moudre. Mais par ailleurs, moi je suis
je pense qu'en revanche, je reviens à ta
question précédente, même si tu vois, tu
les enchaînes tellement que je suis un
peu perdu dans leur imbrication.
Beaucoup de dision, digression.
Mais dans la question précédente, tu
posais la question de l'énergie et je
pense que au fond, moi
je suis un homme de gauche presque à
l'ancienne, tu vois.
Oui, on est bien assis là.
Non mais voilà mais le le la seule
donnée qui vient percuter tout le
système et qui vient le bouleverser en
vérité, c'est la donnée écologique.
Pour moi, c'est pour ça que je reviens à
ta question d'énergie parce que pour moi
c'est la question qui vient bouleverser
complètement la donne. Le le reste, tu
peux être sur la redistribution et tout
ça. Bon, tu sais le le progrès social,
il y a des hauts et il y a des bas. Euh
aujourd'hui, on est dans une phase de
bas durable qui dure depuis 30 ans. Moi,
je situe ça à mars 1983, tu vois, je
suis précis. Carré mars.
C'est quoi ta société idéale ? Ah
non mais attends, je termine. En
revanche euh sur euh l'environnement, on
n'est plus sur un processus qui peut
être cyclique. Ce qui est détruit ne
sera pas reconstruit. Et donc je pense
que c'est la donnée qu'on doit faire
entrer dans le débat et qui vient
bouleverser toute la donne. Ma société
idéale,
j'ai beaucoup de mal à penser en terme
d'idéal. Moi
j'ai beaucoup de mal à voir euh un
regard porté hyper loin sur l'horizon et
me disant "On va aller vers cette
société meilleure et je vous le promets
camarade quoi." C'est pas mon truc. Euh
je suis trop reporter pour ça sans
doute. Je vois ce qui pourrait être
mieux et beaucoup mieux. Je vois pas
d'idéal.
Pas de cap à 30 ans. Pas euh
quoi ?
Pas de cap à 30 ans
de ce que je voudrais ou de Tu sais euh
c'est quoi la formule là ?
Espérer le meilleur
et redouter le pire.
Préparer le pire. Se préparer au pire et
prendre ce qui vient.
Bon, on va t'aider un peu. On va te
poser une autre question. L'immigration,
les murs, euh les flots de migrants, tu
parlais d'écologie de déstabilisation du
climat, les réfugiés climatiques, les
réfugiés
économiques, les réfugiés de guerre.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Bah il faut évidemment maintenir un
accueil humain. Je veux dire d'abord on
il y a il y a il y a le droit et euh il
y a le droit il y a des réfugiés
politiques. Il faut maintenir le droit
pour les réfugiés politiques. Et c'est
un droit qui a considérablement décruis
quand on regarde le taux euh
d'acceptation à l'ofpra. Tu sais,
c'était une fierté dans les années 80
quand on accueillait des Chiniens et on
voit bien comment c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui. Maintenant, tu dans le
projet de loi agriculture par exemple,
j'ai noté et j'ai dénoncé l'absence d'un
volet politique du sud. Parce que si tu
ne penses, si tu penses pas
l'agriculture française en liaison avec
ce qui se passe dans les pays du sud, et
ben en fait, tu produis des réfugiés
économiques. Je Tu me permets de donner
un exemple ou pas ?
J'aime beaucoup Bernard Jon
qui est été un ingénieur agronome et
dans les années 90 dans son pays le
Cameroun après les la signature des
accords de Marrakech de Laron et tout ça
qui font entrer l'agriculture dans le
commerce international il assiste à la
chute du poulet bicyclette. Le poulet
bicyclette c'était le poulet qui était
conduit de la ferme jusqu'au marché
directement au Cameroun. Bon, il était
pas vraiment conduit à bicyclette, hein.
Il venait quand même dans des camions,
ramassé dans les camions et tout ça,
mais enfin voilà. Et euh ce poulet-là
est complètement tué par les
importations de poulet breton, mais
aussi brésiliens et ainsi de suite. Mais
vraiment euh des milliers de paysans,
des dizaines de milliers de paysans qui
se retrouvent sur le carreau. Une chute
vertigineuse et lui, il assiste à ça. Il
commence par mener une enquête, une très
grosse enquête. Il va voir les paysans,
mais aussi il regarde quelle est la
qualité du poulet importé. Il envoie des
poulets à l'Institut Pasteur pour les
faire analyser pour montrer qu'il y a
des bactéries dessus. Résultat, il
arrive à opérer une jonction de classe
entre les paysans et les consommateurs
des villes. Et il fait les
manifestations. José Bovet va là-bas. La
deuxième étape, c'est l'étape de manif.
Euh et José Bosevet va sur place. Il y a
tellement la crainte d'une grosse
manifestation qu'il est condamné à
rester dans l'aéroport. Et la troisième
étape, c'est la phase de négociation. Il
négocie avec l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce, l'OMC Pascal l'a mis à
l'époque pour que le poulet Camerounet
soit sorti des accords euh commerciaux,
ce qu'il obtient. Et la le résultat
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le le Cameroun est
quasiment revenu à l'autosuffisance en
matière du poulet, une renaissance du
poulet camerounais. Et bien ce genre de
décision, ce genre de combat, ça fait
plus pour contenir le problème des
réfugiés euh économiques que des tas de
de de mesures, d'autres mesures. Donc
moi, je pense que la première chose
qu'on devrait faire, c'est euh de
permettre au pays du sud de mener la
politique commerciale qu'il souhaite. Or
aujourd'hui par exemple, j'ai des gens
au bion du kinafacio sur des producteurs
de riz, de céréales et ainsi de suite
qui demanderaient à ce qu'il y ait des
barrières douanières sur le riz pour
pouvoir produire leur propre riz, pour
servir le le marché dans leur coin. Et
ce que me racontent les militants sur
place, c'est que l'Union européenne,
l'ambassadeur de France, le Fond
Monétaire international ou
l'Organisationale du commerce avec tous
ces envoyés sur place font pression sur
le gouvernement Burkinabé et sur en fait
tous les pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest pour
que on remette pas de barrière
commercial, pour qu'on n'insture pas les
barrières commerciales et ça condamne en
fait la production des paysans locaux.
Et voilà, je pense que euh il y a de de
il faut remettre ça au cœur du problème.
Si on remet pas le le maintien des
paysans sur leur terre au cœur du
problème, on est condamné à des flots
permanents euh de réfugiés. C'est pas
comme si les gens ils étaient heureux
quand ils arrivaient. Euh
en attendant en attendant, on fait quoi
?
En attendant, on fait quoi ? Ben, on
prend notre part.
Ce ce chiffre à combien ?
Moi, je sais pas. J'ai pas fait des j'ai
pas fait des statistiques, quoi.
On prend notre part, on en fait quoi ?
On les naturalise tous ? On les
naturalise pas, on fait de la
remigration. On fait quoi ?
C'est quoi la remigration ?
Je sais pas, c'est un terme qui revient
souvent sur internet.
Ah moi [__] j'en sais j'en sais j'en
sais rien du tout. Je vais te dire un
truc. Moi je suis nakalé. Donc là où il
y a
personne n'est parfait hein.
Bon quel problème franchement euh où là
où il y a la jungle régulière qui est
dénoncée, démantelée, qui se
reconstruit, qui revient fatalement
parce que c'est quand même l'endroit où
tu es le plus près des côtes anglaises
et il se trouve que les gars là-bas, ils
veulent pas venir en France. Bon bah
s'ils veulent aller en Angleterre,
pourquoi on les empêche ?
Je comprends pas. J'ai toujours pas
compris. J'ai toujours pas compris que
Sarkozi a signé les accord.
Et les gens qui sont bloqués en Turquie,
pourquoi on les empêche ?
Ben en tout cas, c'est pas c'est pas
Ils veulent venir en Union européenne.
Ben oui, mais le gouvernement
pourquoi on paye les Turc pour bloquer
les
le gouvernement tur ? Bah je j'en sais
rien. Mais tu vois en tout cas pour
l'Angleterre, moi je vois pas du tout
pourquoi on sert de sas contenant les
les migrants qui veulent aller en
Angleterre. Peut-être pour négocier sur
d'autres trucs.
Bah je vois pas sur quoi.
Bah un peu comme la Turquie avec l'Union
européenne
ou mais donc ils y gagnent, ils
négocient sur quelque chose. Moi avec
l'Angleterre, je vois pas sur quoi on
négocie.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On leur
propose des bateaux.
Oui bien sûr. On met on met en accès des
ferries.
Prend l'armée. On prend l'armée, on
prend le Charles de Gaulle et on les met
tous sur le Charles de Gaul.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi il y aurait pas des
ferries tout confort ?
Qui c'est qui va payer
les ferries ? Bah là, je veux dire, moi
je suis prêt à payer. Est-ce que la
France, le gouvernement français paye
des ferries pour aller en Angleterre ?
La date, la dette française, c'est
combien ? Ohà, c'est à peu près le PIB.
Donc on doit être aux alentours de 2000
milliards.
2200 milliards, pas mal.
Ça va non ?
Ouais. Est-ce qu'on construit pas
un champion ?
Est-ce qu'on construit un mur ?
Hein ?
Un mur de quoi ?
Un mur comme avec Trump, avec le
Mexique. Euh
non, pas du tout. Non, non, non.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu en as entendu
parler ?
Non,
non,
non. J'ai jamais entendu parler de
construire un mur. C'est qui est-ce
qu'il y a des idées comme ça ? C'est
Big,
tu sais.
Pas trop parce qu'on est bien informé.
C'est les reportages la télévision, tu
vois sur TF1. La solution au problème
des prisons, c'est qu' c'est qu'il faut
construire des nouvelles prisons.
Forcément, tu sais qui est-ce qui va les
construire. Donc bon. Non, donc non,
j'imagine pas du tout de construire un
mur. De toute façon, moi je suis le
problème central, c'est celui qui est
qui est se trouvait dans le traité
consilier européen, c'est la libre
circulation des capitaux et des
marchandises, y compris avec les pays
tiers. Je veux dire, le problème des des
salariés de whpol aujourd'hui ce matin,
c'est pas euh les mecs qui sont dans la
jungle à calé, c'est pas les réfugiés
libiens. Le problème c'est les
actionnaires américains et pas que
américains. Mais c'est quand même ça le
problème. Le problème c'est que dans
cette Union européenne, on peut
installer le le sèche-linge, la
production de sèche-linge en Pologne
quand bien même 80 90 % et davantage de
la consommation va être dans le nord de
l'Europe, c'està-dire la France, la
Belgique, l'Allemagne et et la
Scandinavie. Donc le problème il est là
et le problème il est celui de la libre
circulation pour moi des capitaux et des
marchandises. Donc c'est c'est à ça que
je veux mettre des entraves pour qu'il y
ait pas la possibilité pour les
multinationales d'aller chercher le coût
du travail le moins cher en dehors de
l'Union européenne et à l'intérieur les
normes environnementales les plus
faibles et euh les coûts fiscaux les les
plus avantageux. Voilà le le le la
donnée clé. Et là-dedans, le poids des
réfugiés à l'intérieur de ça, il est
quand même hyper minime.
Est-ce que tu connais Mayotte ?
Oui, je connais Mayotte. Enfin, je
connais de noms, j'y suis jamais allé
quoi.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire ?
Bah, je peux dire que c'est
la capitale, c'est Mamutu.
Euh, et ce que je peux dire, c'est que
il y a il y a compte tenu du fait qu'il
y a les comor à côté, c'est un lieu que
Bon ben en tout cas, je connais ça, tu
vois. J'ai comme j'ai pas j'ai pas lu
80000 articles dessus. Mais dison, tu as
vraiment décidé de m'interroger sur tous
les thèmes où je me sens pas
Non, mais ça va venir après on va venir
à la convergence des boir une bière en
face à côté. Je me disais c'était pour
ramolir la viande, tu vois. Et je me
trompais pas.
T'inquiète, quand on ramolit la viande,
en général, on prend les rotules.
Bon, alors
alors Mayotte,
bah je sais je sais juste que c'est une
terre d'immigration parce que juste à
côté, il y a il y a les entre autres les
comors et que donc bah il y a plein de
gens qui cherchent à aller à Mayotte
parce que c'est la France et donc ça
crée une situation qui est aujourd'hui
plus que compliquée sur cette île.
Il y avait eu des d'excellents
reportages de Daniel Mermé sur avec
Givanil sur Mayotte.
Le Venezuela, tu veux pas
la Russie ? Les États-Unis, tu veux pas
Israël ?
[__] mais non. Oh non ! Next.
Next. Guerre économique.
Ouais.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur la
guerre économique ?
D'abord, tu sais,
je pense que on met vachement la guerre.
On veut pour moi, c'est un moyen
de nous faire oublier une autre guerre.
C'est-à-dire qu'on nous dit que la
France doit être bagarée contre la Chine
ou l'Europe doit se bagarrer contre les
États-Unis. En fait, on se bagarre pas
trop mais bon et on est on tu vois
d'installer cette ce que tu appelles la
guerre économique, ça nous fait oublier
autre chose qui est la guerre des
classes. Et moi je crois bien davantage
qu'aujourd'hui il y ait une guerre des
classes et il faut qu'on nous dise qu'on
est tous sur le même navire. Du coup, on
est tous sur le même navire France même
s'il y en a qui sont en première classe
et puis il y en a qui sont dans les
soutes mais on est tous sur le même
navire. Donc du coup, il faut qu'on rame
tous dans la même direction, qu'on soit
solidaire euh à bord du même bateau pour
oublier qu'en fait on n'est pas
exactement euh à bord du même bateau. Et
moi, je crois que il y a bien davantage
aujourd'hui une guerre des classes
qu'une guerre économique et queon nous
met ça en avant pour nous faire oublier.
Euh
peut-être que tu te trompes d'échelle,
c'est-à-dire la guerre économique, tu as
laer classe mondialisée et tu as tout le
reste.
Donc tu te trompes d'échelle peut-être.
Je vais dans ton sens là. Oui. Bah oui,
ben donc c'est bien une guerre des
classes puisque tu as la her class la
her classe mondialisée. Je pense queelle
elle est bien consciente que elle a des
intérêts communs. J'avais des citations
des tas de de citations là-dessus qui
montraient qu'en effet euh bah Arnaud se
sent se sent sans doute plus solidaire
de des dirigeants de Facebook de Marc
Zuckerberg que qui ne sans ouvrière de
solidaire de ces ouvriers à Forest en
Cambrésie. Leur mode de vie est plus
proche et ainsi de suite. Bon bah voilà
mais donc tu sais c'est cette phrase de
Waren Buffet. La guerre des classes
existe, c'est un fait, mais c'est la
mienne, celle des riches qui mèent cette
guerre et nous sommes en train de le
remporter. Et il se trouve que que
Warren Buffett qui était à l'époque la
première fortune mondiale, il l'énonçait
sur le terrain du regret quasiment
puisque c'était sur le terrain fiscal et
il disait "C'est pas normal que nous les
riches, on paye proportionnellement
moins d'impôts que ma secrétaire." Et
donc voilà
le CTA, le Mercosour. Ah oui ouais là ça
va, tu reviens sur des terrains qui sont
plus les miens.
Je t'aide parce que on te voit sortir
les rames depuis tout à l'heure.
Bon
alors
comme tu as vu le niveau auparavant, tu
as décidé de de me faciliter la vie. Bon
bah tu vois
c'est reculé pour mieux sauter hein.
D'accord. Mais comme comme on parlait de
l'agriculture bah tu vois là on est en
on est en plein dans le truc. On te fait
un projet de loi agriculture, on te dit
qu'il faut monter en gamme. Les
agriculteurs vont monter en gamme, qu'on
va leur garantir du revenu et ainsi de
suite. Et en même temps, puisque c'est
le en même temps s'impose, on te signe
le mercour, enfin c'est pas encore fait
mais ça va se faire où on te dit qu'il y
aura 90000 tonnes de viandes qui seront
importées. Bon bah déjà c'est un gros
trou dans la raquette quoi. Et ensuite,
on pose la question dans l'hémicycle au
ministre. Mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous garantir que la viande, les bœufs
sur place ne seront pas nourris aux
farines animales ? Silence du ministre,
il ne répond pas. Est-ce que vous pouvez
nous garantir que les bœufs sur place ne
sont pas nourrir aux femmina minimal ?
Il répond pas. On lui pose trois quatre
fois la question, trois quatre fois
silence. C'est une réponse. Et tu as le
rapporteur qui finit par dire "Oui, ben
ben vous comprenez bien, on peut pas
contrôler ce qui se passe là-bas." Je
veux dire, c'est
une grosse quelle qui est mise aux
agriculteurs parce que il est évident
que ça fait ça va faire chuter les
cours. C'est une évidence et c'est aussi
ce qui est mis au consommateur parce que
les consommateurs français ont quand
même fait le choix jusquici de refuser
les farines animales mais on te les fait
rentrer par la fenêtre quoi. Donc voilà.
En tout cas, moi je je crois que tous
les accords de libre échange aujourd'hui
sont une machine à arrêter l'histoire.
Euh oui. Euh c'est-à-dire que
l'histoire, elle pouvait aller dans le
bon sens. On pouvait avoir en France euh
jusque dans les années 70 du progrès
social, euh du progrès fiscal. On aurait
même pu avoir du progrès
environnemental, tu vois. Et euh à
partir du moment où on instaure le libre
échange, on instaure la course vers le
bas. Et ça, si tu veux, nous on a avancé
dans cette histoire-là en en étant dans
le brouillard, euh pas pleinement
conscient et puis il faisait tout pour
nous aveugler avec c'est la paix, euh
c'est le multiculturalisme, c'est tout
ça. Alors que les dominants que tu as
appelé la upper class mondialisée tout à
l'heure, ils avaient tout à fait
conscience de ça. Je me souviens de Gary
Baker, donc un prix Nobel d'économie
mais en version ultra libérale qui dit
"Bon bah voilà le mon le libre échange,
ça sera la même meilleure manière de
diminuer les droits sociaux et de de
diminuer les normes environnementales."
Et c'était intéressant que en deux
phrases ce gars fasse le lien entre les
deux. C'est évident qu'il y a un lien
entre les deux et que aujourd'hui on a
cette difficulté, c'est quand on veut
restaurer du progrès social, de la
justice fiscale ou des normes
environnementales, et bien en permanence
la réponse qui est en face c'est
compétitivité. Compétitivité. Vous allez
nous faire perdre en compétitivité. Donc
on on donc c'est une machine à arrêter
l'histoire et par
les fous ont pris le contrôle de l'asile
et et c'est aussi une machine à arrêter
la démocratie. Bah les fous, ils sont
quand même bien conscients de leurs
intérêts. Pas une forfaiture à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Oh ben ça c'est pas une forfaiture à
l'Assemblée nationale, c'est un
quotidien de forfaiture. Euh
est-ce qu'on sort la
comment on appelle ça ? La faucheuse, la
la
guillotine ?
Moi, tu sais quel est le rôle de la
violence dans l'histoire ? C'est ça que
tu poses comme question ou pas ?
Non, pas du tout. Bon,
c'est quoi alors ? Est-ce qu'on leur
coupe la tête ?
Bah ça c'est bien de la violence quand
même.
Non, ça s'appelle se faire justice.
Ouais. Bon, moi je en tout cas je ça me
semble ça me semble aujourd'hui
relativement inutile. Euh c'est
archaïque.
Bah ce qui m'intéresse, c'est il faut
avoir un niveau euh il faut avoir la
masse avec nous. Tu vois, si jamais tu
n'as qu'une avant-garde éclairée,
c'est cuit.
C'est cuit.
L'avant-garde, c'est comme une
locomotive. Elle doit entraîner derrière
elle des wagons. Si elle regarde pas si
derrière elle entraîne des wagons, elle
va dans le mur. Nous, on peut avoir si
on n pas les gens avec nous, comme on a
pas l'argent, on aura rien. Donc il faut
qu'on ait les gens avec nous. Et si on
regarde pas si en permanence derrière
nous, on a accroché des wagons avec des
gens à l'intérieur, on est foutu. Dans
mon film, Merci patron, il y a un
moment, le commissaire des l'ancien
commissaire des renseignements généraux
vient dire "Mais ce sont les minorités
qui font tout."
Euh et en fait il est beaucoup plus
gauchiste que moi. Moi je
réaliste hein
ou réaliste.
Non, je pense qu'il se trompe pas.
La minorité riche.
Ouais, la minorité riche, c'est vrai.
Mais ceci dit, même la minorité riche,
elle fait bien attention de raccrocher
des wagons derrière elle et sinon elle
gagnerait pas aujourd'hui aussi.
Grisser des pattes.
Euh pas seulement, mais je pense que
elle sait y faire, tu vois. Et lui, il
parlait pas de ça. Les minorités dont il
parlait, c'était les minorités
agissantes, c'était les minorités
activistes. Mais je pense que c'est trop
gauchiste parce que euh il faut vérifier
euh si la minorité elle part toute
seule, elle se désolidarise du reste et
en fait elle n'arrive à rien. Et donc en
permanence, il faut se demander comment
on fait pour ne pas agir tout seul. Et
c'est toute une c'est toute une
difficulté de pas y aller tout seul,
mais de bien vérifier qu'on a on a les
gens ou des gens avec soi, quoi.
C'est pas ce que font les Italiens en ce
moment.
Je crois que c'est le bordel en Italie
quand même. Non mais
en tout cas c'est pas par ce canal là
que que je dirais. Moi, j'y vais par un
canal où tu sais la ce qui est au cœur
de la du triptique républicain, c'est
liberté, égalité, fraternité, c'est
l'égalité. Et cette égalité, c'est ce
qui est le plus oublié, la valeur qui
est la plus pour moi piétinée et oubliée
aujourd'hui. C'est celle que je veux
remettre en notre cœur. Euh, j'ai
interrogé un un épidémiologiste qui
s'appelle Richard Wilkinson qui a écrit
un bouquin euh vraiment formidable.
C'est pourquoi l'égalité est meilleure
pour tous. Et il démontre
statistiquement que dans les pays où il
y a plus d'égalité, les gens vont mieux
mais y compris les riches vont mieux.
Pourquoi ? parce que les inégalités sont
facteurs de stress. Vous sortez de chez
vous et vous voyez des gens qui ne vous
ressemblent pas, soit parce qu'ils sont
SDF, soit parce qu'ils sont super riche.
Et en fait, en permanence, vous devez
vous situer dans cette dans cette
échelle là, vous valoriser. C'est ce
qu'on appelle la rivalité ostentatoire,
avoir le sentiment que l'autre n'est
plus vous, n'appartient plus au même
monde que vous. Et en fait, ça c'est
c'est générateur de stress. Évidemment,
c'est bien plus générateur de stress
chez les dominés que chez les dominants.
Euh mais ça produit du coup des maladies
cardio-vasculaires, ça produit des tas
de trouble. Et il montre Richard
Wilkinson à partir de graphique, il
n'est qu'un analyste statistique
quasiment. Il montre que dans nos pays,
ce n'est plus l'augmentation du PIB qui
fait le plus de bonheur que avec
l'augmentation du PIB au sein de nos
pays développés, on parle pas des pays
africains, on parle pas des pays
asiatiques, là on parle bien au sein de
nos pays développés. Ce qui fait la
différence, ce n'est plus le revenu par
tête, mais c'est le niveau d'égalité au
sein de ces pays. Donc, il faut qu'on en
prenne conscience et de se dire que
voilà, la manière dont on peut
progresser dans notre dans nos sociétés
aujourd'hui, c'est en resterant à plus
haut niveau d'égalité. Euh et donc ça ça
pose tout des questions qui sont aussi
celles de la croissance et de la
décroissance par exemple parce que se
dire que ce n'est plus l'augmentation du
PIB qui fait le bonheur et on le voit
bien sur les pays les plus développés,
les États-Unis sont hyper riches par
tête et c'est un pays où tu as un taux
de détenu par habitant qui est colossal,
un taux de suicide qui est important.
Ouais, mais oui, mais ils ont plein de
pognons. Mais tu vois, ça résout pas le
euh le le problème, le un taux
d'obésité, un taux de toutes les
maladies sont hyper fortes là-bas et euh
ils sont en fond plus malheureux.
Donc
mais il propage ça partout dans le monde
le rêve américain.
Bah euh
c'est un problème d'ailleurs, tu vois,
tu as un espèce de packbo. Pour moi, je
pense que aujourd'hui c'est comme si
idéologiquement on parlait de 2005, mais
le packbo, il a commencé très largement
à tourner. Ça fait plus rêver.
Aujourd'hui, on était à 55 % en 2005.
euh contre euh cette ce traité
constitutionnel, contre la concurrence
libre et non faussée, contre la libre
circulation des capitaux et des
marchandises. Et pourquoi il ne nous
repose pas la question ? Pourquoi jamais
il ne nous repose la question ? Et
pourquoi jamais ils ne nous la
reposeront ? Parce qu'ils savent
qu'aujourd'hui on serait plus à 55 %, on
serait à 65 %. Ce projet-là, il est mort
chez le peuple, il est mort dans les
têtes et pourtant il continue à le faire
avancer, tu vois.
Et ça fonctionne.
Et ça fonctionne. Ça fonctionne non pas
par adhésion, mais ça fonctionne par
apathie. Et donc comment on sort de ça ?
Et ben, il faut retrouver le chemin
d'une autre espérance. Il faut être pass
capable de passer du non 2005 à un oui
pour bientôt.
Comment tu vas faire ?
Comment je vais faire ? Moi, j'espère
pas être tout seul par faire des
calendriers, tu vas faire des petites
manifestations, tu vas faire quoi ?
Tu sais, les manifestations, euh
il faut trouver, moi je cherche en
permanence le truc qui va
qui va combattre au quotidien
l'indifférence. Mais ouais, tu vois. Et
ouais, ouais, ouais. Mais tu sais, c'est
un c'est un dur combat la glaise de
l'indifférence. C'est c'est Gramchi qui
parlait de ça. Comment tu as
l'impression de t'enfoncer dans un
bourbier, d'être dans un marécage ?
D'ailleurs, tu vois euh c'est mon côté
digression qui se fait marrer, c'est ça
? Mais je fonctionne que par digression.
J'ouvre des parquos.
Vas-y, continue.
D'accord. Euh mais donc on forme parfois
un tandème avec Frédéric Lordon.
Ouais.
D'ailleurs, on lui passe le bonjour
monsieur qui fait sa star. Bon et donc
euh et si tu veux par exemple, je me
souviens au moment de Merci patron, moi
je suis un reporter, ça veut dire que je
suis enlysé dans la désespérance
quotidienne des gens. Oui. Euh je je
vois des gens qui vont pas bien. Je vais
rencontrer des gens qui vont pas bien,
qui m'expliquent leurs problèmes et
ainsi de suite. Et je pas je suis dans
la gadou là-dedans, tu vois. Et c'est
contagieux.
Tu finis toi aussi par patoger, par te
sentir, tu vois, [__] qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire ? Et tu as l'ordon euh
qui lui voit pas comment ça patoge, tu
vois, qui vient pas de patoger avec toi,
qui du coup débarque en te disant bah
voilà l'horizon et machin. Et tu dis
[__] mais il est barche ce mec quoi.
C'est pas possible. Et en fait c'est un
soulagement parce que il t'arrache
plus que toi.
Il t'arrache non mais il t'arrache à ta
à ta ta Gadou et il vient te porter vers
autre chose. Bon bah des moments tu as
besoin de ça même si tu sais que c'est
pas c'est pas cohérent avec le réel. Tu
sais c'est
le la pire phrase c'est c'est comme ça.
C'est-à-dire la totologie le ça qui
renvoie au ça et c'est comme si on
pouvait plus en sortir. Comme s'il y
avait un espèce de de cercle vicieux de
serpent qui se m un coup parce qu'on
t'entend plus là
quoi.
Bo un coup on t'entend plus. un chat
dans la gorge.
Donc
tu sais euh c'est truc un chat est un
chat, un sous est un sous mais c'est la
réalité. La réalité c'est la réalité tu
vois le réel c'est le réel et comme si
tu pouvais pas sortir de ce réel là
comme si en gros jamais ça n'avait été
autrement. Nulle part ailleurs n'est
autrement et jamais dans l'avenir ça ne
sera autrement. Et ben nous, il faut
qu'on s'appuie sur tous les cas où
auparavant ça a été autrement, ailleurs
c'est autrement. Alors, comment tu vas
faire avec des gens qui sont abrutis
toute la journée par des séries de
merde, avec des télénovelas de merde,
avec un quotidien de merde, avec une
bouffe de merde, qui sont pas informés,
qui ont une un accès à l'information de
plus en plus restreinte, qui ont pas le
temps de s'informer, qui ont des
problèmes avec Bobon, qui ont des
problèmes avec les gamins, qui ont des
factures à payer. Tu fais comment pour
les sortir de leur torpeur et de leur
catatonie émotionnelle ou de leur
catatonie citoyenne ? Tu sais euh
tu fais comment
dans euh la
tu fais comment concret concret
je te dis le problème il est pas tu
places le ça sur le problème sur un plan
cérébral et euh sur le plan de la
conscience et sur le plan de est-ce
qu'ils sont assez informés mais les gens
sont assez informés oui les gens ont
déjà tranché
est-ce qu'ils comprennent l'économie
mais ils ont oui ils la comprennent et
s'il la comprenait il y aura une
révolution demain
mais attends ils la comprennent
l'économie et la preuve c'est que sur le
traité conc européen, tu avais 80 % des
ouvriers qui ont voté contre, tu avais
71 % des employés qui ont voté contre,
67 % des chômeurs qui ont voté contre.
Donc, tu avais un vrai vote de classe.
Ça prouve que les gens ont compris le
lien entre leur situation et ce type de
texte là. Et demain, si les mêmes
questions étaient posées, on aurait un
vote de classe qui serait encore plus
prononcé. Donc, les gens ont compris. Le
problème n'est pas de comprendre. Le
problème est d'espérer. Le problème
c'est d'avoir un chemin qui te dit que
tu peux sortir de ce comme ça.
Quel est le cap ?
Ben, il est pas évident à tracer. C'est
comme il est pas évident à tracer de de
c'est une c'est un tel nouveau monde à
inventer que tu Oui, moi je je suis plus
doué pour le petit pas, tu vois. et de
faire que moi déjà il y ait des gens qui
aient confiance en ma parole euh qui
aient confiance dans ce que je porte.
Euh je suis plus l'homme des petits pas
que l'homme du grand horizon et
peut-être que c'est avec Frédéric Lorn
qu'il faut voir quel est le grand Pap.
Moi je pense que aujourd'hui
on a touché tes limites là.
On a touché tes limites.
Je veux dire c'est pas mes limites. Tu
touches l'une de mes limites mais mes
autres limites sont nombreuses. Et tu as
par exemple pu le voir sur la politique
internationale. Et je je me considère
pas comme quelqu'un d'intelligent, tu
vois. Je me considère
opératif. Tu es
ça veut dire quoi
? C'estd que tu fais
peut-être. Ouais. Bon, je pense queavant
de faire, il faut quand même avoir pensé
un petit peu ce que tu vas faire. Mais
mais en effet, j'essaie de faire.
Le glyphosate, tu étais où ?
Le glyphosate, j'étais où ? J'étais dans
ma chambre, je pense hein. J'étais dans
ma chambre à l'Assemblée nationale.
Alors sur le glyphosate, je n'étais pas
sur les bancs des insoumis quand a été
voter le l'amendement, il me semble 220
ou quelque chose comme ça, mais enfin
bon sur le glyphosate. Euh maintenant,
moi j'ai siégé
sur ce texte de loi sur l'agriculture du
mercredi du mardi
de ça doit être de 9h30 du matin jusqu'à
1h30 du matin, mardi, mercredi, jeudi,
vendredi, samedi, dimanche. Dimanche
soir, je suis allé fêter la fête des
mères à ma mère à Amien. Le lundi, je me
suis mis en repos et j'y suis retourné
le mardi. Donc voilà, tu vois, la
question pour moi, elle est pas
celle-là, elle est comment ça se fait
qu'on organise les débats de cette
manière-là ? Comment ça se fait qu'on
organise les débats de 9h30 du matin
jusqu'à 1h du matin et weekend compris ?
Comment ça se fait que le président de
régie fait deux choses ? Il décide de
nous faire siéger le weekend constamment
comme la loi asile et immigration qui a
été votée un dimanche soir. Est-ce que
tu crois que c'est normal qu'on vote des
texte aussi important que ceuxl un
dimanche soir ?
Ou encore un mois d'août
voilà qu'on soit pour ou qu'on soit
contre. Tu vois
c'est fait à dessin
évidemment. Oui,
c'est une grave accusation.
Mais non mais attends, j'accuse de
rugie. J'ai aucun problème à accuser de
rugie. Pourquoi ? Parce que il y a un
cordon ébélical qui n'est pas tranché
entre l'exécutif et le législatif.
Aujourd'hui, le parlement est une
chambre d'enregistrement des désirs du
président avec François de Rugie comme
surveillant, tu vois. Et donc, c'est le
complice quotidien des désirs du
gouvernement. Évidemment qu' sur un
projet de loi comme l'agriculture, il
doit bloquer 2 semaines pour qu'on ait
le temps d'étudier ça du lundi au
vendredi comme des gens normaux dans la
journée que tu vois qu'on n'aille pas
siéger. Ça s'est terminé à 3h du matin
dans la nuit mardi à mercredi. Là, j'y
étais tu vois. Et à la fin, normalement,
il devait y avoir des prises de
position, des positions de vote des
députés sur le texte et la présidente a
décidé de zapper les positions de vote
des députés pour pouvoir terminer euh à
l'heure. Moi qui ai pris la parole, on
m'a accusé de produire du mal-être chez
les salariés de l'Assemblée nationale.
Bon, j'ai discuté avec les salariés de
l'Assemblée nationale pour le dire
est-ce que vous considérez que je fais
votre malheur ? Mais bon, ils m'ont
regardé en disant non, c'est pas ça le
problème quoi. Mais par contre, ça fait
11 jours qu'on est là. Ça fait 11 jours
qu'on est là du matin au soir qu'on
qu'on voilà qu'on a des conditions de
travail qui sont extrêmement dures.
Ils sont payés combien ?
Oui, tu sais euh et je dirais pareil
pour un certain nombre d'autres
professions. Je on peut revoir les payes
des gens et tu sais que j'ai revu la
mienne, d'accord, mais euh le fait
d'être bien payé, ça n'empêche pas que
très bien payé ces gens.
Ouais. Mais ça n'empêche pas que tu dois
être traité correctement. Tu peux revoir
les payes, mais c'est pas une raison
pour mener les gens au burnout. C'est
pas une raison pour mener les gens à
l'épuisement. C'est pas une raison pour
traiter les gens comme de la merde.
C'est pas parce que les gens sont bien
payés que ils doivent être maltraités,
tu vois. Et et je dis et évidemment,
c'est pas parce que les gens sont euh
sont mal payés qui doivent qui ve qui
doivent être maltraités non plus parce
que le système, il maltraite tout le
monde, tu vois. Il fait pas trop de
distinction euh entre les deux. Mais
donc voilà. Donc là la question c'est
aujourd'hui c'est couper le coordonical
entre le le l'exécutif et le législatif.
Et or euh on a un président de
l'Assemblée nationale qui fait tout au
contraire pour que l'Assemblée nationale
ne soit pas un lieu vivant. Évidemment,
il arrive, on est à il est 1h 10. Je n'y
suis pas avant hein. Tu vois, j'ai pas
nié que je je n'étais pas là avant. J'ai
fait ma j'ai pris mon lundi. C'est
scandale. T
copains de la tes copains de la France
insoumise, il faisaient quoi ?
Mais tu sais, on nous demande d'être en
mission, on nous demande d'être en
commission euh tu vois, on nous demande,
on est 17, on nous demande d'être
partout, on nous demande d'être en
circonscription aussi. Donc voilà. euh
tu en plus tu vois il peut y avoir une
lassitude qui s
ça a été fait exprès pour laisser le
glyphosate.
Mais oui enfin c'est évident que quand
François de Rugie voit arriver le truc
sur le glyphosate et qu'il est 1h du
matin normalement on lève la séance à 1h
du matin
parce que l'Assemblée nationale est sous
l'emprise de lobby
moins que l'Élysée.
Mais oui de toute façon c'est même pas
des lobby à l'Élysée c'est leur pentin
tu vois et tu regardes le parcours
d'Emmanuel Macron va voir une loi sur
les fake news. C'est une vraie rigolade.
Tu veux réguler ce qui se passe dans les
médias et ce que tu fais c'est une loi
sur les fake news. Bon, il lui est venu
ce caprice. Donc en plus faut voir
comment ça marche. Tu vois, il veut pas
faire une proposition une un projet de
loi parce que s'il fait un projet de
loi, il faut faire une étude d'impact.
S'il fait une étude d'impact, ça
repousse le la le le projet de 4 ou 6
mois. Donc ça sera pas valable pour les
élections européennes et il veut que ça
soit fait pour lui pour les élections
européennes. Donc il trouve un député
qui tient à l'idée concomitante en même
temps que le président de la République
de d'une loi sur les fake news. Tu vois,
il trouve un pentin pour lui porter son
projet. un ventrilo, c'est un numéro de
ventriloi. Donc voilà comment ça comment
ça se passe. Mais je veux dire, tu veux
réguler les médias en France et ce que
le seul truc que tu trouves à faire,
c'est les fake news. Je veux dire,
regardons les relations de de d'Emmanuel
Macron et de la Garder.
Bah oui, regarde ce ce qu'a fait
Emmanuel Macron et avec la Garder.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ? Il est chez
Rothchill. Quand il est chez Rothchill,
il s'occupe du groupe de presse d'Arnaud
Lagard. Il revend un certain nombre de
magazines. Il fait il fait gagner du
pognon à la Gardre, tu vois. Ensuite, il
passe à l'Élysée. Déjà, il était arrivé,
c'est déjà du pantouflage dans un sens,
il repart pantoufl dans un sens. Il
devient conseiller économique de de
François Hollande. Qu'est-ce qu'il fait
là ? Il gère les affaires de la gardère
sur le côté Airbus. Tu vois, sortie à la
gardère de Airbus. C'est un truc qui va
rapporter un paquet de pognons colossal.
à la Gardèire, tu vois, son client d'
euh d'avant, il le sert à l'intérieur de
l'Élysée. Normalement, ça c'est ça
devrait péter à la tête de tout le
monde. Et c'est ce mec-là qui nous a
fait une loi sur la moralisation de la
vie publique, tu vois. Donc non mais
attends, c'est incroyable. Bon et donc
euh et 3è point, il est candidat à la
présidentielle.
Regarde la presse la gardère, regarde le
nombre de une du JDD, regarde comment il
a été servi. Bon ben c'est tout. Et si
tu veux faire une loi sur l'information,
tu l'as fait mais tu t'attaques au
problème. Regarde, il y a une une, je
l'ai pas amené, c'est dommage, mais
enfin, il y a une une de euh du Parisien
sur Bon, euh donc euh le PDG de
Carrefour, l'homme qui va révolutionner
la grande distribution. Tu vois, au
moment où Bonard annonce 2400
licenciements chez Carrefour, moi j'ai
des tas de petits magasins chez moi qui
ferme, tu vois, à la fois des gens qui
auront plus de quoi s'acheter de la
bouffe dans leur Carrefour City machin à
côté de chez eux et en même temps des
salariés qui sont virés. Tu as des tas
de caissières qui vont être virées à ce
moment-là. Le titre du parisien c'est
l'homme qui va révolutionner la grande
distribution. Tu te rends compte
pourquoi
c'est beau ?
Et pourquoi ? Parce que Bonpard
Carrefour actionnaire principal Bernard
Arnaud le parisien
actionnaire principal Bernard Arnaud
donc tuas en fait Bernard Arnaud qui
fait la pub de son propre magasin à la
une de son journal mais nulle part il
n'est inscrit dans le parisien serait le
minimum d'honnêteté attention notre
actionnaire notre propriétaire c'est
l'actionnaire dominant de chez Carrefour
tu vois nulle part s'inscrit bonne au
passage
ami et soutien de de d'Emmanuel Macron.
Mais si tu prends la liste salophi
salopi, tu vois euh donc le le grand
laboratoire pharmaceutique euh qui quand
même a produit avec la dépakine des des
dizaines milliers vraisemblement
d'enfants autistes. Euh bon euh tu tu
regardes euh qui supprime des usines qui
n'ont jamais servi. Une usine qui n'a
jamais servi à à Montpellier
sur les fake news. Te perds pas.
Ouais. Ah non mais alors sur un fake
news. D'accord. Mais là, j'étais parti
sur le lien au départ, c'était sur
l'Élysée euh comme lieu en fait. C'est
même pas les lobbyes, tu sais. Lobby,
c'est un terme qu'il faudra ne plus
employer. Je t'expliquerai pourquoi
après.
Mais ça nous fie euh donc euh euh
scandale de la dépakine euh destruction
d'une usine et de milliers d'emplois
mais destruction de la recherche. Ça
veut dire que là on n'est pas seulement
sur un problème social, on est sur un
problème sanitaire. Prise de contrôle
par les actionnaires, politique de cash
à fond. Donc destruction d'un outil
sanitaire par le le le pressage des
actionnaires. Bon, on pose la question
là-dessus à Édouard Philippe
dans l'hémicycle. Il nous répond "On ne
peut pas critiquer une grande entreprise
française. On Castaner avait été
quelques jours plus tôt sur le site de
Sanofi. On ne peut pas critiquer une
grande entreprise qui est qui réussit."
Et de la même manière, Édouard Philippe
était allé voir Weinberg, le PDG de
Sanofi sur l'un de ses sites et c'était
quelque chose qui avait été fait
discrètement qui était qui était fait à
la demande du cercle de l'industrie. Je
sais pas si tu connais le cercle de
l'industrie. Donc un truc fondé par
Stroscan mais qui était un vrai un vrai
nid à lobby quoi. Et donc et on en tient
informer ni les syndicats, ni les
Français, ni les salariés, ni les
médias. Personne n'est au courant de la
visite de Ddouard Philippe, tu vois.
et qui a été le seul invité enfin à un
moment Emmanuel Macron, tu sais lors de
du passage de relais avec François
Hollande en mai, fend la foule, on voit
ça sur BFM, il fend la foule et il va
voir qui ? Il va voir Serge Weinberg.
Qui est Serge Weinberg ? C'est l'homme
qui lui a permis qu'il a rencontré dans
le truc Atali, la commission Atali et
qui lui a permis de rentrer chez
Rothshield, tu vois. Et donc [__] mais
il est entouré par ça. Et donc
évidemment il est impossible de
critiquer Sanofi aujourd'hui. Le fait
que Sanofi paye pour le scandale de la
DPAIN c'est impensable pour le
gouvernement français. Il va préfér le
gouvernement risque de préférer payer
plutôt que de faire payer Sanofi. Et
c'est pas pour les bienfaits de
l'industrie française, c'est pour les
bienfaits de cette oligarchie. Tu sais,
je te disais lobby c'est un terme qui
qui convient pas. C'est un truc dont
j'avais discuté avec Geoffrey Ghen qui
est un universitaire belge qui travaille
beaucoup sur l'Europe. Je parlais des
lobby à Bruxelles. Bon, on peut raconter
plein d'anecdotes là-dessus mais il me
dit non, c'est vraiment une mauvaise
manière de voir les choses parce que ça
suppose qu'il y ait deux choses
séparées. Que euh il y ait d'un côté les
parlementaires et la Commission
européenne et qu' d'un c de l'autre côté
les lobby qui font pression sur eux.
Mais c'est pas ça comme ça qu'il faut
regarder. Les c'est pas des lobby les
intérêts du grand du grand capital de
l'oligarchie, ils sont représentés
directement par la Commission européenne
sans sont des marionnettes. Macron, je
prétends même pas, c'est une erreur. Je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure mais tu sais
quand tu as c'est une facilité de
langage de dire que les lobby font
pression sur Macron. Ils font même pas
pression. Il en est pénétré.
Il est il est pénétré du fait que faire
le bien des plus riches dans le pays,
c'est faire le bien du pays. Il voit la
société française à travers cette classe
qui est la sienne, celle qui rencontre
tous les jours, c'est ses visiteurs du
soir. Il est baigné là-dedans. Tu vois,
je me baladais dans ma circonscription
au moment où il a décidé de faire l'exit
taxe. Je rencontrais une association de
demandeurs d'emploi qui aidé à faire de
la mobilité qui va être supprimée, un
étudiant qui pourra pas poursuivre ses
études et ainsi de suite. Et paf, à ce
moment-là où je fais ces rencontres là,
il fait l'exit taxe près d'un milliard
d'euros 800 à 900 millions d'euros.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les gens qui
rencontrent quotidiennement, c'est des
gens qui sont confrontés à cette grave
difficulté de devoir payer cette taxe.
Mais c'est pas les gens que j'ai
rencontré dans mon coin, les demandeurs
d'emploi. Le jour où ila les rencontrer
eux, ça fera les images, ça fera les
photos et puis tout ça, mais ça
n'arrivera qu'une fois.
Bon, pourquoi la loi sur les fake news
avant les élections européennes ? Parce
que ses copains veulent de l'Union
européenne à Gogo. Parce que peur que
les médias russes influencent la
politique intérieure contre l'Union
européenne ? Pourquoi ?
Moi je crois russe ou américain.
Ouais mais moi je crois que
foncièrement, tu vois, je vais te dire,
moi je disais tout à l'heure merci Marc
Duurberg.
Euh je veux dire que je n'existerai pas
aujourd'hui comme figure. Je me permets
de penser que je suis une petite figure
de la vie politique française. Je
n'existerai pas aujourd'hui comme figure
si je devais compter sur les médias
dominants.
Tu vois, par exemple, cette nuit là, le
le gros scandale, c'est que ma chemise
est sortie du pantalon et j'étais par
exemple la première fois que ma chemise
est sortie du pantalon et que ça fait
des ravages
sur dans les grands médias, c'était la
nuit où j'avais dénoncé ça dans la
moralisation de la vie publique sur
Macron, sur la Gardère, sur Sanofi et
j'y avais été franco et je m'étais pris
des des gens dans l'émissie qui m'a dit
qui me disaient "On jamais parlé d'un
président comme ça." Et je sentais que
c'était euh euh que ça bougeait, que
c'était, tu vois, que c'était heurant,
moi je savais pas si je devais le faire,
mais enfin, on était dans un attent
instant intense. Et le seul truc qui
était ressorti de cette nuit-là dans les
médias, c'est Ruffin a sa chemise sortie
du pantalon. Merde.
Technique classique.
Ouais, mais tu vois euh et heureusement,
il y a pas que ça, tu vois. Mais il y a
un autre truc, c'est une fois je parle
de je vais parler je pose une question
au gouvernement sur la dépakine réponse
scandaleuse desir Philippe et pour une
fois je me dis tiens je vais me faire la
salle des quatre colonnes tu sais là où
il y a tous les journalistes qui
grouillent. Je déteste ce tru là
grouille comme de la vermine.
D'habitude j'y vais pas mais bon là je
me dis je veux le porter j'y vais
j'arrive c'est qu'est-ce que vous pensez
du drapeau de l'Union européenne ?
[__] mais tu vois je tu cherches à
porter un truc qui te tient à cœur et
tout ça et heureusement il y a internet.
Heureusement, il y a internet et du coup
bah tu parviens à contourner ça. Tu tu
montres qu'en fait il y a un paquet de
gens qui sont intéressés par autre chose
que les querelles à de balles et et du
coup les médias ensuite vont s'en
emparer éventuellement mais seulement
après. Donc moi je crois que en fait au
fond le réflexe contre les fake news
enfin sur chez Macron est un réflexe de
grande méfiance à l'égard de des canaux
qu'il ne contrôlent pas. C'est de la
peur
en tout cas. Tu vois, on parlait du
traité constit européen. Il est évident
qu'à l'époque les médias faisaient
campagne pour le Oui, mais aujourd'hui,
il y a des canaux souterrain de
diffusion de l'information et ça il les
contrôle bien moins. Et je pense que là,
il y a des lieux d'expression, il y a
des terrains pour faire passer des idées
divergentes et ainsi de suite. Vous vous
en êtes un.
Bah d'idées divergentes. Bon bah, tu
vois ce que tout ce que je viens de te
raconter là, ce que vous faites, ce que
vous faites sans doute chaque semaine
là, il y a des il y a les idées peuvent
passer par ce billet là. l'idée que on
doit sortir de la croissance. Je veux
dire, c'est un mythe, moi je suis
accroissant, je suis même pas
décroissant, tu vois, je suis
accroissant. Mais il faut en finir avec
la croissance. Il faut en finir avec
l'espérance de croissance et de croire
que c'est la croissance qui va nous
conduire à améliorer nos vies. Je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure, c'est pas vrai.
Ça te fait pas faire des cauchemars
quand tu dis ça ? Parce que je te donne
un exemple. Nos marchés financiers
sont basés sur une fonction
exponentielle. Notre dette est basée sur
une fonction exponentielle. Si tu
commences à vouloir faire de la
décroissance, les marchés financiers
vont convulser.
Bon,
tu sais, moi j'ai déjà fait tout un tout
un bouquin euh qui rappelle dans
l'histoire les solutions à la dette.
Donc, il peut y avoir l'inflation comme
solution à la dette qui est la plus
récente qu'on a utilisé, mais il y a
peut y avoir un certain nombre de
solutions, c'est
la déflation et la stackflation.
Non, non, mais il y en a d'autres, tu
vois. C'est simplement ne plus payer.
Euh, c'est de mettre ceux auprès de qui
on a des dettes en prison. Colbert
l'avait fait, tu vois. Donc il y a un
certain nombre de de de décisions qui
peuvent être prises sur le terrain de la
dette.
Les chinois en prison,
hein,
tu vas mettre les chos en prison de
toute façon. Et ben écoute, ne payons
plus si si vraiment la dette, elle est
auprès des Chinois, ne payons plus notre
date et puis ça ira. Tu vois,
tes chaussures c'est made in China. Tes
chaussettes, c'est made in China, ton
jean c'est made in China. Ouais, ouais,
ouais. D'accord. Et alors, tu vois ? Bon
et alors je veux dire, on est on est en
permanence placée, on est dans un bain
capitaliste et on peut pas faire comme
si on en était extrait. Tout geste que
tu fais est lié en effet à une
multinationale. Vous film tard.
Non, je crois pas que ça soit trop tard.
Bah de toute façon, si c'est trop tard,
on arrête et puis on fait quoi ? On fait
plus rien, tu vois. On rentre chez soi.
Bon, terminé. Euh donc voilà. Non. Euh
et donc
toujours un espoir. Bon,
en tout cas, tu sais, c'est euh le
pessimisme de la licité, l'optimisme de
la volonté. Donc voilà. Donc c'est tout.
Il faut il faut maintenir ça. Et puis
les jours où je suis en dépression, ça
m'arrive, je me montre pas. Revons sur
les fake news. Ria, ça te fait penser à
quoi ?
J'y suis jamais passé.
Pourquoi ?
Euh je sais pas. Euh
parce que il y a des gens à l'intérieur
qui ont qui ont invité à voter pour
Marine Le Pen et que c'est pas trop mon
truc quoi.
Lequel ?
Ouais, je cite pas. Non, tu vois.
Si il faut des noms.
Non non non, c'est bon, c'est bon.
Voilà. Donc
vas-y, reprends ton petit verre où il y
a du miel dedans là.
Ouais.
Dans l'autre. Voilà.
Non non, c'est bon. Voilà.
D'accord. Spoutnik ?
Non, je sais pas trop. Je je regarde pas
trop tout ça honnêtement, tu vois.
Bon, pendant qu'on te laisse t'éclaire,
je te dire moi je reste un gros lecteur
de bouquin. Bah ouais, tu tu fais les
yeux aussi.
Quel est ton quel est ton dernier
bouquin ?
Je suis en train de lire Mobidic. Tu
vois
qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Rien. Je t'écoute. Je suis en train de
lire ma fiche. Qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ?
Je sais pas, tu tuas ça l'air de pas te
plaire comme littérature mobique. Si si
mobidique, c'est bien.
Tu sais la question c'est quand tu es
dans un espace aussi clo que l'Assemblée
nationale où on se demande une forme de
terrorisme législatif,
tu dotes, tu votes, tu appuies sur ton
bouton, tu appuies sur ton bouton, on
t'a écrit un texte
pour pour porter t amendement. Bon,
c'est comment tu fais pour maintenir
sortir de cette mécanique et avoir autre
chose à rapporter ? Il faut de l'air du
dehors. Et l'air du dehors, c'est soit
les gens, soit des bouquins, soit tout
ça. Mais il faut absolument maintenir
ça. Et j'ai l'impression que tu sais
dans les reproches qui sont fait aux
députés, vous êtes pas là t taata,
c'est qu'on voudrait avoir des robots.
Mais mettez des robots. Moi, je c'est
pas ça que je j'espère. J'espère porter
une forme d'humanisme. J'espère porter
des valeurs. J'espère trouver des moyens
d'expression. Mais ça ça demande à
respirer. Ça demande de tu vois, ça
demande pas d'être le nez collé aux
amendements, à l'alinéa 1, alinéa 2 et
machin. Et si je deviens ça, je vais me
dessécher, je vais me racornir.
Qu'est-ce qui va rester de mon âme ?
Faut que je faut je la sauve mon âme.
Non,
tu as une âme ? Est-ce que tu as un ami
imaginaire ? Est-ce que tu crois en Dieu
?
Non, malheureusement.
Pourquoi malheureusement ?
Bah parce que quand même de penser que
après la vie, il y a encore de la vie,
c'est un truc qui peut être rassurant,
non ?
Bon, on va te faire une petite pause là
comme ça.
Bien Jacques Chancel et Dieu dans tout
ça.
C'est ça. Ou Marc Hulman.
Le journalisme, la liberté de la presse
en France, ça en est où ? Qu'est-ce que
tu en penses toi en tant que journaliste
? La carte de presse, ça sert à quelque
chose ?
Bah ça ça fait une déduction fiscale.
7500 €.
Ouais. Euh je l'ai plus hein moi pour te
pour te dire mais quand même euh à part
ça ça aide à rentrer dans un certain
nombre de trucs mais enfin ça c'est pas
non plus un pass donc c'est pas la carte
de presse qui fait moi au contraire je
suis assez attaché au fait que le
journalisme il y ait du flou dans ce qui
est un journaliste et qu'on accepte
ce flou que il y a pas besoin de faire
d'école par exemple je suis contre
l'école obligatoire que un tel serait
journaliste et pas un tel serait
journaliste à partir du moment où tu
interview des gens
euh où tu écris des articles, où tu
publies, tu vois, tu es journaliste en
fait dans les faits. Moi, j'ai pas j'ai
pas été journaliste à partir du moment
où j'ai eu ma carte de presse, j'ai
lancé Faqu en 1999 et je suis
journaliste depuis 1999 à partir du
moment où j'ai pris la plume, quoi. Donc
après, il y a tout le système des grands
médias don que je t'ai décrit. Et c'est
là on va peut-être en revenir à l'âme.
Et il y a la loi sur le secret des
affaires sur lequel je me suis beaucoup
plus bagaré que je ne vais le faire sur
les fake news quoi. Mais je crois que le
désir de vérité euh le désir de porter
autre chose, porter des valeurs, de pas
se laisser enfermer dans le seul argent
roi, ils peuvent faire toutes les lois
qu'ils veulent. Il y en aura toujours
pour le porter.
il y aura quelque chose qui résistera
dans les hommes. Et tu sais quand je
vois le parcours de Denis Robert par
exemple, les 97 ou 93 procès qui s'est
payé à peu près tout dans tous les coins
d'Europe et en tout cas partout en
France, le tour des tribunaux qu'il a eu
à faire, tous les huissiers qui sont
passés chez lui, les menaces sur lui,
sur sa famille et tout ça. C'est pas une
loi de plus type secret des affaires qui
fait qu'il aurait canné. il avait une
vérité à porter et il l'a porté et il
aurait il l'aurait porté dans toutes
conditions. Donc moi je crois que quoi
qu'il fasse, il y aura quelque chose qui
résistera en l'homme. Maintenant le
problème c'est que du coup les porteurs
de vérité doivent devenir des héros
quoi. Et c'est ça le problème c'est que
on il faudrait queon puisse faire son
travail normalement d'information. Tu
vois moi je trouve remarquable ce que
fait Élise Luin. Je suis vraiment un
amoureux d'Élise Lu quoi. C'estes
magazines elle t'a radicalisé ? Euh non,
je pense pas qu'elle avait besoin.
Pourquoi ?
Tu sais, tu sais, je pense pas qu'elle
avait besoin. C'est elle qui s'est quand
même radicalisé dans son parcours qui
est quand même très intéressant quoi.
Donc donc voilà
la liberté de la presse.
Bah tu quand tu regardes
les magazines d'Élise Lucé, moi j'avais
fait un j'avais porté un amonement
pendant le secret des affaires qui était
l'obligation pour les les grandes
entreprises d'ouvrir leurs portes et
l'obligation pour les dirigeants
d'entreprise de répondre. C'est-à-dire
que c'est comme si tu avais aujourd'hui
des firmes enfin des des un pouvoir qui
était absolument colossal et dont le
rendu qu'ils avait à faire aux citoyens,
aux consommateurs et tout ça était
quasiment nul. un homme politique, on
lui demande des comptes en permanence et
soit tu vois euh un un
un fonctionnaire, on peut on peut lui
demander des comptes dans sur les
décisions qu'il a prises
qui
qui euh tu peux
tu es pas promu quand il fait des
conneries,
il peut c'est je dis pas que le système
soit parfait mais je pense qu'on peut
aller l'emmerder. Je pense que les
médias sont autorisés à aller l'emmerder
comparé au pouvoir dont dont il
par exemple la nana qui a bloqué Riatou
devant l'Élysée avant-hier là
la nanais la la la responsable de la
communication de l'Élysée qui a bloqué
le journaliste RT qui avait sa carte de
presse. Est-ce qu'il faut aller attraper
son nom et et l'allumer en place
publique ? la nana qui a été envoyée
pour faire ça
et qui a été euh secondé par l'officier
de gendarmerie qui a dit euh voilà ça
vient de plus haut, on vous fera pas
rentrer, c'est le président qui a dit
ça.
Bah je veux dire là, tu viens de me dire
quelle est la cause de tout ça. Je veux
dire celui qu'il faut allumer, tu viens
de le nommer, c'est le président, c'est
celui qui décide de faire ça quoi. Non,
qui ne respecte pas la carte de presse,
qui
fait de la discrimination envers des
journalistes.
Bah oui, c'est évident. C'est évident
que si si la cause
Est-ce qu'il faut pas taper le
fonctionnaire qui est le pouce bouton ?
Par exemple, le mec qui conduait le
train qui était de la SNCF et qui a
conduit des juifs dans des camps ?
Ouais, tu sais en l'occurrence
je trouve que c'est un exemple malvenu
quand on sait que les plus gros noyaux
de résistants ont été dans la SNCF. Tu
vois, bon, je il faut quand même
rappeler ça au moment où l'entreprise
ferroviaire est attaquée. Euh mais euh
euh
tu sais par exemple
que le devoir de retrait chez les
fonctionnaires est un peu oublié.
Bah il faudrait qu'il puisse s'exercer.
Maintenant c'est comment tu fais pour
pour agarantir un statut au lanceur
d'alerte ? Tu vois ? Et admettons, tu
vois, dans le truc tout le truc secret
des affaires, moi je disais si vous
voulez faire le secret des affaires,
d'abord on va le restreindre parce que
là en fait votre secret des affaires,
c'est pas que sur secret industriel et
commerciaux, c'est à peu près surtout.
C'est-à-dire que si tu sors la fiche de
paye d'un dirigeant, on peut consister
considérer que c'est une atteinte au
secret des affaires. Si on sort un
document comme quoi il va y avoir un
plan de licenciement dans la semaine
prochaine, c'est une atteinte au secret
des affaires. À peu près tout peut
rentrer dans le secret des affaires
aujourd'hui. Mais par ailleurs, moi
j'étais pour construire un deuxième
volet qui soit un volet positif pour
contrebalancer. Vous vous assurez ça au
multinational ?
Très bien. Et bien alors rajoutons ça et
assurons ça à la société civile.
Assurons ça aux journalistes. Assurons
par exemple de pouvoir accéder à tous
les rapports de l'inspection du travail,
de la direction de l'environnement quand
elle va chez l'actalis. Rendez ça
public. Rendez le public. Met faites le
mettre automatiquement sur les sites
internet. C'est pas un truc
révolutionnaire, c'est un truc exact. Il
existe aux États-Unis, il est un he le
Transparency Act. Donc tu vois la
transporisation de ça en France, refus,
mais aussi euh voilà le fait que il
puisse y avoir par exemple dans les
abattoirs, moi je suis pour que dans les
abattoirs, il y ait pas forcément de
vidéosurveillance mais qu'il y a un
libre accès euh des ONG et euh des
journalistes aux abattoirs, mais plus
généralement aux entreprises. Moi,
j'étais journaliste local pendant 10 ans
que à mien et dans la somme la
principale entreprise privée c'était
Goodieur, tu vois, c'était le plus gros
truc de toute la Picardie. Et ben en
disant, je n'ai jamais pu accéder à
l'usine goodur.
Le seul truc où je pouvais aller,
c'était le local syndical où tu as des
néons qui clignotent et puis tu as tu
bois un café sur une table en formica.
Tu vois et c'est tout ce tout ce que
j'ai vu et ce qu'on me décrivait de
l'usine avec les mecs qui galèrent sur
le bambur qui en sortent la gueule noire
les odeurs. Je on a plus que me le
raconter. On en aucun cas je n'ai pu y
accéder. je n'ai pu le voir, je n'ai pu
le sentir moi-même. Et bien, je pense
que c'est un souci démocratique et donc
il faut faire ouvrir ça. Il faut qu'on
puisse voir aussi comment les gens
travaille.
Les associations qui infiltrent ce genre
de d'abattoir. Est-ce que tu es pour ?
Tu es contre ?
Je suis absolument pour. Non, je suis
pour. Maintenant, on résoudra pas le
problème des abattoirs et plus
généralement de l'élevage industriel par
la seule somme de dénonciation. Euh
qu'on aille un coup dans un élevage en
Bretagne, qu'on aille un coup euh dans
un abattoir dans le sud de la France,
leur donner un statut de lanceur
d'alerte.
Oui,
oui, oui. Mais surtout, il faudrait
qu'il y a un statut pour les lanceurs
d'alerte. Aujourd'hui, il y a rien
quasiment. Tu vois,
Snowdon, il faut lui accorder la la
nationalité, l'asile politique, il faut
lui faire quoi ? J'y suis absolument
favorable.
Julia Nassange, le regroupement
familial, on en est où ?
Moi, je suis favorable aussi. Voilà, je
pense que Snowden et ainsi de suite,
c'est des gens qu'il faudrait absolument
défendre euh et on se grandirait à le
faire. Bon, quand
pourquoi on le fait pas ?
Bah parce que aujourd'hui euh parce
qu'on a baissé notre culotte devant les
États-Unis. C'est une évidence absolue.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable encore.
Non mais non, mais je veux dire, on peut
énoncer un certain nombre de truismes
comme ça, mais quand tu vois comment au
moment où on a appris qu'on était
espionné par les États-Unis et que la
réaction a été on a fait semblant
de s' mouvoir et puis la semaine d'après
c'était oublié, tu as compris qu'on est
des carpettes aujourd'hui.
On a expulsé aucun diplomate américain.
Bah parce qu'on a mais parce que on a
instauré aucun rapport de force avec les
Américains sur ce côté. Peut-être qu'on
peut pas.
Bah moi je suis de ceux qui croient
queon peut. Tu sais
comment
il faut vouloir. Je veux dire, il faut
vouloir. Bah tu vois, tu lui dis
Snowden, on l'accueille. Quand tu
imagines, c'est Snowden, qui est-ce qui
a été rapatrié ? On a cru qu'il était
dans un avion, on a fait contrôler le
ciel. Tu te souviens plus de cette
histoire là ? Snowden,
c'est c'était Snowden. Bon, attends,
on a fait atterrir, je crois, le
président péruvien ou Bolivarien ou
Ouais, mais c'est un truc de dingo. Tu
vois, on coupe des avions dans le ciel
parce qu'on se dit le mec est peut-être
dans l'avion et on est tellement complic
des États-Unis alors qu'ils ont rien sur
ce cas-là. Je veux dire, ce mec a rendu
service. Il a rendu service, tu vois.
Donc c'est de on est des vallées dans
ces cas-là. Et évidemment, je souhaite
que sorte, c'est pas mon grand truc, la
politique internationale, on l'a
compris, mais enfin, je souhaite qu'on
soit pas des vallets, quoi. Président
bolivarien qu'on a fait atterrir.
D'accord.
On n'est pas des Valais. On sousraite
notre enseignement aux États-Unis. Sans
la NSA, on peut pas faire de guerre
contre le terrorisme. Qu'est-ce que tu
penses du du concept de guerre contre le
terrorisme ?
J'en suis pas un spécialiste.
J'avais fait un j'avais interviewé Oh
merde ! Comment il s'appelle ? Un mec du
monde
qui avait publié un bouquin.
Samuel Laurent. Non, il publie pas le
bouquin lui.
Non. Ah merde, je me souviens plus du
monde des livres. et qui euh qui faisait
une analyse de qui étaient les
djihadistes. Bon et et le à la racine de
tout ça, de toute façon, ça va pas
résoudre les les les conséquences, hein.
Mais à la racine de tout ça, c'est
quelle quelle espérance tu remets. Je
parlais de l'espérance pour les classes
populaires, mais il y a aussi
l'espérance. Quelle espérance tu remets
dans les quartiers ? Et si la seule
espérance qu'on a apporté, c'est celle
hyper matérialiste de consommer
davantage, ça n'est plus une espérance.
Et donc il faut qu'on ait qu'on porte un
autre idéal, quoi. Et voilà, je vois
combien
la quête d'idéal est complètement
tordue.
Donne-nous ton idéal.
Je crois que je suis simplement porté
moi par la continuité de de la
Révolution française et par une
espérance de de grande fraternité quoi.
Déjà d'abolition des classes.
D'abolition des classes quoi. De tu sais
la la en tout cas c'est pas un idéal
parce que je t'ai dit que j'étais pas
très fort en ça et tu vois je j'envoie
le j'envoie l'absence aujourd'hui. Je
sais pas si je l'ai pour le si j'ai
quelque chose pour le remplir mais en
tout cas la devise qui pourrait qui que
je trouve la meilleure c'est celle d'vem
dans comment les riches détruisent la
planète et qui tient en quatre mots.
C'est consommer moins, répartir mieux.
Consommer moins c'est la nécessité
écologiste et répartir mieux c'est
l'urgence sociale. Et je pense que une
fois que tu as tu as mis ces quatre mots
là ensemble tu as la direction en tout
cas dans laquelle moi je souhaite aller.
Donc c'est très bien tu me lances sur le
prochain sujet. La collapsologie ça fait
penser à
Ça veut dire qu'on va tout va tout va
s'effondrer.
Il te reste un peu de miel he si tu
veux.
Je sais pas si tout va s'effondrer. En
tout cas, je sais qu'il faut être prêt
euh à euh à remplacer.
Oui. Euh ça veut dire qu'il y a des
moments, il y a des fonettes qui
d'opportunités qui s'ouvrent. Tu vois,
soit on considère qu'il y a il y a euh
euh les choses vont aller lentement et
puis tout ça. Je pense qu'il peut y
avoir la crise de 2009, on en a discuté
avant au bistro, mais
qui n'était pas un bistro d'ailleurs.
Ah bon ? C'est pas un bistro. C'est quoi
?
C'est une cave àabi bière.
Ouais. Bon, c'est un genre de bistro
quand même, non ?
Mais donc on on la la crise de 2009, on
a un moment où le libéralisme chute et
où les les tenants de ce libéralisme
vont en direct à la télévision pour se
battre la coulpe en disant "C'est
scandaleux tout ce qu'on a fait. On
aurait pas dû produire de l'endettement
comme ça. Vraiment la finance a pris le
pas sur l'existence des gens. On on doit
plus faire ça et ainsi de suite." Tu
veux rajouter quelque chose ?
On a surtout un baril de pétrole qui
flirte avec les 147,90.
Ouais, mais enfin bon, toujours est-il
queil viennent en direct pour dire ça.
Et là, si tu veux, les manifes qui sont
faites, des grosses manifes, hein, quand
même, il doit y avoir plus d'un million
de personnes à cette époque-là. Je dis
peut-être des conneries, faut vérifier,
hein. Mais en tout cas, il y a trois
grosses manivres d'affilé, euh, me
semble-t-il, au printemps 2009. Et le le
thème de la manif, c'est nous ne
payerons pas leur crise. Ça veut dire
qu'il y a rien. Ça veut dire que on a
rien à proposer. Ça veut dire que le
contreprojet, il est pas là pour être
mis sur la table. Genre nationalisation
du crédit, tu vois.
Le Glass Eagle Act aussi
par exemple. Mais tu vois, c'est une
espèce de mesure minimale le Glass Eagle
Act
qui consiste à
qui consiste à la séparation des banques
d'affaires des et des banques d'épargne,
on va dire, des banques de dépôt.
Bon, mais c'est un espèce de truc
minimum. comment on est sorti de cette
crise là sans même avoir notre
cette décision là, c'est absolument
incroyable. Mais de manière plus
général, quelle politique douanière on
met ? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à la
libre circulation des capitaux et des
marchandises ? Il y a zéro réponse à ce
moment-là, tu vois. Et résultat,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Tel un sphinx
qui renaît de ses cendres, et ben le ce
libéralisme s'est remis sur ses pieds
jusque peut-être le prochain la
prochaine crise, le prochain
effondrement. Mais si jamais nous de
notre côté on n' pas fait mûir un
certain nombre d'évidences, c'est-à-dire
pas juste des évidences théoriques dans
trois livres portés par trois
intellectuels, mais des des évidences
qui se sont disséminées dans la société
française et qui font qu'on l'a comme
mesure de remplacement immédiat quand
leur truc il chute et ben ça sera une
nouvelle fenêtre d'opportunité qui est
qui s'ouvrira et qui se refermera. Donc
il y a l'un des travaux que nous avons à
faire, c'est de porter des idées et de
les amener à maturation et de les
disperser dans la société française.
Même si elles paraissent aujourd'hui
inutiles, même si le climat politique
n'est pas prêt à les à les à s'en
emparer, et bien demain se fera
s'ouvrira peut-être une fenêtre
d'opportunité dû à un collapse à une
chute qui fait que ça sera le moment de
les mettre à l'intérieur de cette de
cette fenêtre. Voilà l'une une petite
partie de mon travail quoi.
Tu parles de demain. Est-ce que tu as vu
un reportage sur article qui s'appelle
Demain tous crétins sur la la proportion
des perturbateurs endocriniens à
ralentir la capacité cognitive des gens
et surtout des nouveaux nés ?
Non, j'ai pas vu ça. Mais en revanche,
pour préparer le secret des affaires,
j'ai regardé bah ouais, tu sais, tu vois
comment tu Je vais te dire sur
Tu penses pas qu'il y a une dissonance
cognitive entre la réalité des faits et
la capacité des gens à comprendre ce qui
se passe réellement ?
Ben de tous, de moi commencer, moi je je
me crois pas intelligent, tu sais. Je
t'ai déjà dit, hein. Donc
sans doute qu'il y a une dissonance.
Mais tu sais par exemple sur la le le
fait qu'on devienne moins intelligent,
moi ce que j'ai vu qui potentiellement
pouvait me rendre moins intelligent,
c'est internet. Euh je vais t'expliquer,
mais c'est le téléphone portable, les
SMS. Maintenant, j'ai un fil télégram et
tout ça. Pourquoi ? Parce que quand tu
écris euh il y a toujours un moment où
tu tu vois ta pensée, elle devient un
peu floue. Tu sais pas ce que tu vas
écrire ensuite tu butes. Et en fait,
c'est le moment le plus intéressant.
C'est le moment où tu es, tu dois
chercher autre chose, tu vois. Et si
jamais là tu as un accès internet,
qu'est-ce que tu fais au moment où tu
butes ? Tu vas aller contrôler ton mail,
tu vas aller regarder le fil Telégram et
tu perds le fil de ta pensée. Et donc je
pense que euh
c'est toi qui fait ça parce que nous
quand on bute, on va voir nos copains de
la communauté pour s'endurcir.
Bah peut-être mais tu vois aller voir
les copains de la communauté, je suis
pas sûr que ça soit un truc qui
maintienne la concentration. Moi je te
dis juste en terme d'écriture, j'ai
senti combien ma capacité de
concentration, elle pouvait être entamée
par un un genre de truc multitâche
permanent. Et ça, je l'ai senti euh sur
mon cerveau et c'est une lutte pour moi
euh que de réussir à me m'en de de le le
le de de le le maintenir à distance euh
tu vois de de ne serait-ce que lire.
Quand tu es plongé dans un truc
d'adrénaline comme les la vie politique
où on te demande des tas de trucs en
même temps où tu as des des assistants,
des machins qui te posent des questions
et tout ça, tu peux toujours répondre en
permanence à des sollicitations et du
coup lire ou écrire qui sont des trucs
qui demandent du temps, qui demandent
une certaine continuité intellectuelle,
c'est quelque chose qui devient séquencé
et quasiment impossible. Et tu sais
quand j'avais été euh j'ai déjà
rencontré des députés auparavant quand
j'étais journaliste, je me disais
[__] ils sont cons.
Ils sont quoi ?
Con
ou prétentieux.
Ouais mais tu vois c'était juste tu leur
demandais il il lisait plus, il lisit
plus il tu vois qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
comme contenu intellectuel ? Il y a il y
avait plus grand-chose. Tu dis "Mais
c'est pas possible d'être amené à
produire des lois, devoir réfléchir à
comment fonctionne la société française,
vers où on veut l'emmener." Euh tu vois,
sans lire.
Et je j'étais rencontré à confronté à ce
vide. Et c'est pour ça que je voudrais
pas que il y ait un côté j'ai tu vois le
vide des gens mais je te dis sur
l'économie les gens ils ont compris
l'essentiel plus que l'élite
sur la création monétaire ils ont
compris
en tout cas par exemple tu vois sur les
questionsage
sur les questions de
tu connais le vieill adage si les gens
comprenaient le système financier demain
il y aura une révolution
mais tu vois je crois pas
je n'y crois pas à ça mais oui parce que
qu' vont jamais comprendre Non, je crois
pas que à partir du moment où tu as
compris, ça te ça te suffise à produire
une révolution ou à te à produire même
une révolte parce que
le découragement, je je sais pas, il
faut mesurer ça, cette résignation
quotidienne de pas avoir non plus de
voix qui te porte, tu vois. Donc
tu verrais qui porter la voix ? À
Jean-Luc.
Bah en tout cas, il l'a porté. Euh
il a fait combien,
hein ?
Il a fait combien ? Ben d'abord, il faut
voir de de où tu pars et où tu arrives.
Non, il a fait combien ?
Il a fait 20 % à peu près.
Et c'est suffisant ?
Ben, c'est une étape. En tout cas, c'est
mieux que de là où on est parti. Tu
vois, moi j'ai j'ai vu mon camp. Euh
c'est quoi ton camp ?
Mon camp, c'est la gauche.
Tu vois, j'ai vu
gauche le PS.
Non, ça fait longtemps que je considère
pas que le plus que le PS soit de
gauche. Ça veut pas dire qu'il y aura
pas il peut pas y avoir des alliances à
l'avenir. Ga caviar
Benoît Amont. Benoît Amon, c'est ton
copain ?
Non mais euh c'est quelqu'un ?
C'est quelqu'un que je que j'ai
rencontré. Mais
tuas rencontré, c'est bien. Mais c'est
ton copain ou pas ?
Non, c'est pas du tout mon copain. Mais
je veux dire
parce que je l'ai vu deux fois, tu vois.
Je l'ai vu deux fois. Donc c'est pas
quelqu'un je au niveau de ses valeurs,
c'est un opportuniste, c'est quoi ?
Non, je dis pas que c'est un
opportuniste. Il je sais pas, il trace
son chemin, il appartient à la En tout
cas, j'ai aucun doute sur le fait que il
appartienne à la gauche, tu vois. C'est
pas grave. Mais et de toute façon, il
faut il faudra demain construire quelque
chose où on soit ensemble, c'est
l'évidence pour moi. Et on va pas on va
pas construire des cloisons. J'ai je
suis pas là pour construire des cloisons
entre les gens. Manuel Vals, tu tu veux
faire des
Non mais non mais non, ça c'est c'est
tout. C'est terminé là. Tu passes à
autre chose. Tu es entre Benoît Amont et
Emmanuel Vals, tuas tuas tu as un
faossé.
Bah pourquoi tu lui tendrais pas la main
?
Non non. Bah non parce que il est de
droite mais ça fait longtemps qu'il est
de droite. Tu vois même de toute façon
c'était le mec tuis c'est c'est le truc
j'ai fait un bouquin qui s'appelle la
guerre des classes et dans laquelle en
gros c'était un bouquin sur le Parti
socialiste, tu vois en particulier sur
Vincent Payon. Heureusement tu vois
c'est là qu'on voit que la vie politique
française se clarifie à un moment c'est
que maintenant les S gens savent même
plus qui est Vincent Payon. Donc donc
voilà, mais tu avais je dire Emmanuel
Val, c'est quand même celui qui propose
de supprimer le nom du Parti socialiste.
Bon, peut-être que en effet ça aurait
été un exercice de vérité mais c'est
quand même la branche la plus àroite du
Parti socialiste qui fait 2 % aux
élections primaires et et qui se
retrouve 4 %. Tu vérifieras parce que je
sais que vous vérifiez tout en direct.
Donc ici, on se méfie, on se dit
"Putain, faut pas que je raconte trop de
conneries
chez nous".
Je me suis dit faut pas que je sois
précis comme ça. En étant pas précis, tu
vois. précis
et ben qui se retrouve premier ministre.
Je veux dire c'est euh Mais déjà
Hollande bon moi je me suis intéressé à
Macron quand il est devenu conseiller de
Hollande. Déjà Hollande était clairement
pas un type de gauche, tu vois, mais
depuis les années 80. Euh il il est
volontaire pour que la gauche soit de
droite. Bon euh mais quand j'ai vu qu'il
recrutait Emmanuel Macron pour lui
parler à l'oreille et pour être le
porte-voie des patrons à l'oreille de
Hollande euh voilà c'est là que je me
suis intéressé à Macron. C'est pour ça
que j'ai lu ses biographies et tout ça
très vite je me suis intéressé au
personnage.
Alors présidentiel Amon il a fait 636 et
Mélenchon il a fait 1958.
Ouais
pour information.
Mais je parlais de Vals à primaire.
Ouais. Bon, on va laisser Blanco Blanco
tout seul. La fête à Macron, c'est pas
énerver les gens pour rien.
Quand tu vois des mecs brûler des
effigies de Macron comme si on était en
Iran.
Bah, d'abord ça ça s'est pas passé à la
fête à Macron puisque tu tiens à être
précis.
Ça s'est passé dans la manif des
fonctionnaires qui a suivi. Donc c'était
pas du tout dans la fête à Macron.
Donc voilà. Non, je pense pas que
c'est pas par effet boule de neige.
Non, je pense pas que les gens ils ont
tu sais ils ont pas besoin de moi pour
détester Emmanuel Macron et moi
ils ont besoin de toi pour canaliser
leur pouvoir démocratique.
D'abord, ils ont peut-être pas besoin de
moi tout court, hein, tu sais. Faut pas
Non,
principe de Peter, c'est ça ?
Non, là, j'en suis pas encore au
principe de Peter. Principe de Peter,
donc c'est le principe où on dépasse son
niveau de compétence et on devient
incompétent. Pour l'instant, je trouve
que ça va encore. Mais après, vous
pouvez vous pouvez avoir des avis qui
qui soient pas convergents. Je pense que
pour l'instant ça va encore. Non, c'est
dans la situation qui est la nôtre.
Qu'est-ce qu'on essaye ? Tu sais,
c'était le le c'était Roosevelt qui au
moment de la la crise aux États-Unis dit
"Le peuple nous en voudra pas d'échouer,
mais il en il nous en voudra de ne pas
avoir essayé." pas ce que fait Macron.
Nous devons essayer quelque chose. Non,
je pense pas que Macron Macron alors là
bon tu as problème si tu m'amènes sur
Macron, on peut y passer. On aurait pu
faire la totalité de l'entretien. Ça
aurait été un vrai fil conducteur. Euh
non. Euh Macron, c'est le nouveau visage
d'une vieille politique. J'avais dit à
un moment c'était le satchirisme à
visage poupin. Tu vois comme on disait,
le socialisme à visage humain. Mais je
veux dire la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron, c'est celle de la gauche et de
la droite depuis 1983. En 1983, François
Mitéan doit faire un choix, c'est est-ce
qu'il sort du système monétaire européen
? Est-ce qu'il instaure du
protectionnisme ou est-ce qu'il se il se
résout à une politique déflationniste,
une politique de mise en concurrence des
des salariés français avec les salariés
européens ? Bon voilà et il fait ce
second choix et c'est ce que à l'époque
Lionel Jospin appelle qui était premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste
l'ouverture de la parenthèse libérale.
Cette parenthèse libérale, elle n'est
toujours pas refermée. Elle est toujours
pas refermée à gauche. Et donc Emmanuel
Macron, la politique qui mène
aujourd'hui, c'est pas du tout une
politique originale. Il amène avec plus
de force et plus de virulence que ses
prédécesseurs sans doute. Mais je dirais
que c'est presque la phase terminale
d'un processus. J'espère. Tu vois,
peut-être que c'est une fa une fausse
espérance, mais c'est pousser à bout la
logique de 1983. Mais je vois pas
grand-chose de neuf dans sa politique
sur le terrain économique et social. Euh
c'est euh il faut diminuer, en gros, il
faut diminuer le coût de le coût du
travail. Bon bah, c'est pas quelque
chose qui est très original. Même ces
trucs là, il va faire une loi sur
l'apprentissage mais c'est déjà ce qu'on
ce que racontait le Parti socialiste
dans les années 80. Donc on est dans une
vraie continuité. Il faut aider les
entreprises, il faut diminuer les impôts
pour les riches, il faut diminuer les
impôts pour les multinationales, sinon
elles vont partir ailleurs. On a ce
discours-là, c'est celui de de la droite
et de la gauche depuis de gouvernement
depuis les années 80. Donc on n'est
absolument pas sorti de ça. Juste le la
force de Macron, ça a été que
à un moment, et c'est ça qui pour nous
est désarsonnant,
c'est que on pense que l'histoire elle
était en train de changer, que le
protectionnisme avait plus le vent
poupe, que le libre échange avait
terminé et Macron, il vient réussir à
réunir le centre gauche et le centre
droit, à tout mettre sous sa coupe et du
coup à encore constituer un bloc qui est
plus fort que
les forces du nom, quoi. Et donc il
réussit ce ce tru là en faisant
fusionner les deux centres, on va dire.
Et donc ça ça c'est c'est ça représente
une vraie puissance. Mais sur le
bien [__] quand même.
Oui oui, tout à fait. Mais pas que enfin
je veux dire quotidiennement.
C'est quoi de français pour François
Ruffin ?
Oh merde, il a plus rien là-dedans. Fall
je passe à euh pour François Rfin
français.
Écoute,
c'est quoi ? c'est lire la lettre de
Guimoke. C'est quoi ?
Euh moi c'est l'histoire socialiste de
la révolution française par Jean Jorè.
C'est continué à être apporté Mirabo. Je
sais que y compris dans la gauche dans
la gauche enfin surtout dans la gauche,
il a pas bonne figure Mirabo mais c'est
Mirabo
Denton, Robespierre, Mara, Gracus Babuf
et je signale que tous ces hommes-là ce
sont des hommes que Jores fait sien
parce que maintenant la figure de Jores,
c'est voilà, c'est formidable et tout
ça. Mais quand on lit l'histoire
socialiste de la Révolution française,
Jores considère bien que tous ces
hommes-là, ce sont ceux qui ont porté
ensemble le bloc de la révolution
française. Et donc je porte ça,
c'est-à-dire un idéal égalitaire. Tu
vois la Révolution française, c'est ce
moment avec tension et fruction. Quand
on me dit que c'est une révolution
bourgeoise, çaen est peut-être le
résultat, mais ça n'en est pas la
dynamique. C'est toute l'originalité de
la révolution française. Mais tu vois,
tu me portes là, je me porte moi-même
sur un sujet que j'aime bien. C'est que
la Révolution française
pour contester le pouvoir du roi et de
l'aristocratie, la bourgeoisie s'est
alliée au peuple. Tu vois, ce qui n'a
pas été le cas en Angleterre. La
bourgeoisie en Angleterre, elle s'est
alliée à l'aristocratie. pour contester
le pouvoir royal. Mais elle s'est pas
allié au peuple. Tu veux que je
t'explique pourquoi ? Ou parce qu'il y a
eu Louis XIV. Louis X, il a eu à faire
face à la Frede et en faisant face à la
Fronde, il a vu le l'alliance qui
pouvait exister entre les nobles et la
bourgeoisie. Et donc tout son souci à
Louis XIV a été de pouvoir casser cette
alliance possible entre les nobles et la
bourgeoisie, tu vois. Et qu'est-ce qu'il
a fait ? Il a fait Versailles.
C'est-à-dire qu'on extrait les nobles de
Paris. Donc on extrait les nobles des
demeures bourgeoises, on les coupe de la
bourgeoisie et on les amène sous la
tutelle du roi à Versailles. Et de la
même manière, il avait près des très
gros habits. Je sais pas si tu tu vois
les habits avec lesquels il est décoré,
des perruques et tout ça qui coûtent
super cher. Et pourquoi pour un lancer
une mode et faire que les nobles
s'endettent pour se payer des habits
comme ça. Et du coup étant endetté, ils
étaient sous sa coupe, tu vois. Donc euh
donc il y a pas eu de euh étant sous le
il a créé une une symbiose entre le roi
et l'aristocratie, du coup quand éclate
la Révolution française, quand la
bourgeoisie veut davantage le pouvoir,
elle peut pas s'appuyer sur
l'aristocratie. Donc sur qui elle
s'appuie ? Elle s'appuie sur le peuple.
Elle s'appuie sur le peuple et ça donne
des phénomènes complètement contraires,
des phénomènes de moments de fusion, de
moments de tension, des moments où ça se
déchire. Mais ça fait toute
l'originalité de la Révolution française
qui pendant 6 ans et c'est son moteur,
c'est une révolution qui dure 6 ans et
qui voilà et parce que il y a la
jonction des classes populaires euh et
de la bourgeoisie. Il y a il y a une
alliance à des moments comme ça et donc
alors voilà, je pense que c'est un truc
qui vont être les autres dates, ça va
être 1936, ça va être mai 68 mais bon
voilà et ça va être des grandes figures
comme Jorè, comme Valè et je pense que
c'est surtout la littérature en fait tu
sais quand on me demande être être
français, je pense que c'est quand même
beaucoup la littérature.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des black ?
Tu vois, je me suis référé à Jores. Euh,
c'est quoi les yeux au ciel ? Tu aimes
pas Jores.
Si si, j'aime beaucoup. C'est que je te
lance et que tu comprends pourquoi je te
lance.
Euh et à la fin du 19e siècle euh il y a
le mouvement anarchiste qui opère la
propagande par le fait, c'est-à-dire par
des par les bombes. En espérant que le
fait de tuer des parlementaires, mais
des gens, on va dire, de l'oligarchie ou
de l'élite de l'époque va faire que le
peuple va rejoindre le le l'avant-garde.
Bon, et qu'est-ce que ça produit ? ça
produit l'inverse. C'est-à-dire que
voyant ça, le peuple ne veut pas aller
avec ce qui ce qui tuent, ceux qui
cassent. Bon et donc le mouvement
anarchiste décline. Qu'est-ce qui de mon
point de vue a mieux fonctionné ? C'est
le mouvement socialiste. Le mouvement
socialiste n'exclut pas la violence mais
s'il y a une violence, c'est une
violence de masse. Ce c'est pas la
violence de quelques individus. Et
surtout, il faut d'abord avoir les
masses avec soi, tu vois. Et donc c'est
la c'est la ligne choisie par Jouress.
Et je considère que le mouvement
socialiste a apporté beaucoup plus que
le mouvement
que le mouvement anarchiste. Je je me
situe de ce côté-là. Ça veut pas dire
que je lis pas des tas d'auteurs
anarchistes. Ça a commencé par Octave
Mirbau et plein d'autres mais et que je
je trouve pas des choses très
intéressantes
chez mais chez un certain nombre de
théoriciens. Mais je me situe de ce côté
de l'histoire et aujourd'hui encore je
me situe pas du côté anarchiste. Voilà,
je suis député. Ça veut dire que j'ai
j'ai fait l'effort de convaincre une
majorité de gens de chez moi que j'étais
là pour porter leur voix. Et c'est le
chemin que je choisis. C'est encore le
chemin de la masse,
la surveillance électronique
par les bracelets,
par les algorithmes, par la loi
renseignement, par la loi de
programmation militaire, par
J'en suis pas un un grand spécialiste.
Encore une note de mes limites, tu vois,
tu pourras le rajouter dans la liste qui
est déjà la longue.
Est-ce que tu as un avis sur les Civic
Tech ? Je sais même pas ce que c'est.
Bon, on va te laisser te renseigner. Euh
euh G On va passer aux questions
internet. Est-ce que tu peux me remonter
la liste s'il te plaît ? Remonte tout en
haut. Encore encore. C'est tout.
Alors, question. La solution c'est pas
de réformer la démocratie. Est-ce qu'on
n'est pas impuissant aujourd'hui ?
Bah euh
bon, moi je je dis toujours la
démocratie n'existe pas. se fait exister
et chaque jour euh si vous
si vous transférez des articles, vous
participez un peu à la démocratie. Si
vous écrivez un article, vous y
participez. Si vous distribuez un tract
ou bien si sur votre lieu de travail
vous défendez un salarié qui s'en prend
plein la tronche, vous faites exister la
démocratie. Donc la démocratie, elle
tombe pas du ciel. Chaque jour, on y
renonce. C'est comme une Si on y
renonce, c'est comme une falaise qui
s'érode tous les jours. Donc notre
devoir, c'est de la faire exister. Moi,
j'essaie de la faire exister. J'essaie
de montrer que quand même on peut
l'ouvrir. Ça change ça que change pas
grand-chose aujourd'hui mais si on est
plus nombreux demain, ça peut changer
quelque chose. Donc c'est de réveiller
quelque chose à ce niveau-là. Maintenant
maintenant il est évident que les
institutions sont plus qu'à réformer.
Elles sont à bousculer, elles sont à
chambouler. Euh voilà, je je l'ai dit le
rôle du parlement et je j'ai bien vu
qu'il y avait une fonction tribunicienne
du parlement. Tu vois, comme un tribin,
tu peux aller prendre la parole, tu peux
venir contester, être une voix pour les
gens, mais c'est pas là que se fait la
loi de toute façon et c'est pas loi là
que tu as un véritable poids pour la
transformer. Donc qu'il faille bousculer
les institutions de manière radicale,
j'en suis tout à fait convaincu.
Autre question internet. Quelle mesure
pour que les députés fassent bien leur
travail ? Moi euh
goudrons les plumes.
Non mais moi je te le redis, je pense
que aujourd'hui le problème il est de
côté de l'Élysée et l'Élysée est très
habile et euh fait regarder du côté de
l'Assemblée en disant euh regardez comme
il bossent mal comme les band sont v
d'abord les gens bossent mal parce
qu'ils ont ce sentiment que leur travail
est inutile. Donc moi, je souhaite un
renforcement du régime parlementaire
quitte à ce que il y ait une dose de
tirage au sort chez les à l'assemblée et
ainsi de suite, mais je suis pour un
renforcement des du pouvoir du parlement
face au président. Et si je moi je suis
pas arrivé député par hasard. J'ai je
suis arrivé député parce que je
considérais qu'il y avait un véritable
rôle à jouer et que dans un pays si on
veut être une démocratie, il y a pas
juste un bonhomme audessus qui décide
tout. Mais il peut au moins il y en
avoir 577 derrière qui qui ont un
certain pouvoir. Donc voilà quel est le
truc. Alors moi je crois que pour que
les députés travaill, il faudrait déjà
qu'ils aient un véritable pouvoir. Ça te
ça t'incline pas dans ton boulot à à
bien faire ton boulot quand tu as le
sentiment que tu peux tu changes rien.
Tu vois on le fait quand même. Mais je
le dis c'est plus sur moi sur la
fonction tribunicienne de prise de
parole que sur la fonction législative
de vraiment fabriquer la loi. C'est la
première chose. Et ensuite moi je suis
favorable au doublement du nombre de
parlementaires.
Payer comment et combien ? payer comment
? Tu sais le le budget de ça, c'est 60
millions d'euros. Je veux dire déjà on
là, j'ai demandé à à euh je je l'appelle
même pas assistante parce que Johanna,
elle est plus qu'une assistante, ça fait
des années qu'elle m'accompagne et euh
il y aurait pas eu la fête à Macron, il
y aurait pas eu Merci patron et il y
aurait pas eu euh Nuit Debout si Joanna
avait pas été là comme logisticienne.
Donc c'est une manière de lui rendre là
comme ça
l'importance de son rôle. Voilà. Mais
euh je lui ai demandé de me faire des
tableaux euh pour me montrer euh le la
diminution euh du nombre de
parlementaires par habitant. Euh c'est
absolument considérable. Je crois que
euh au moment de la Révolution
française, on est à un parlementaire
pour 27000 habitants, il me semble. Il
faudrait vérifier. Mais
tu connais les chiffres en Allemagne ?
Euh euh ils sont c'est un peu plus que
nous. C'est l'un des c'est le seul pays
où où ça soit plus que nous en Europe,
tu vois. Mais et donc aujourd'hui on
doit être à un pour 74000 ou quelque
chose comme ça. Mais demain l'objectif
de de Rugie et de Macron, c'est de nous
a ramener à un pour plus de 100000. Moi
je pense que je préférerais qu'on ait
davantage parlementaire. Moi je
souhaiterais de pouvoir ne siéger qu'une
semaine sur deux. Hop ! Alors, j'ai
entendu Ouais, il veut moins bosser mais
c'est pas vrai. Je veux mieux
travailler. Je veux pouvoir avoir aller
rencontrer tranquillement les gens dans
mon coin de passer une semaine dans
l'hémicycle, OK ? Mais aussi aller
passer une semaine au contact des gens,
voir comment ils vivent, qu'est-ce
qu'ils ressentent, comment ils espèrent
pouvoir transformer la situation,
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire.
Continuer à m'informer si c'est sur
l'agriculture, aller visiter des
élevages, des abattoirs et tout ça et
pas seulement être le nez collé à des
textes de loi. Donc, je crois qu'il faut
rendre du pouvoir au parlement. ça nous
donnera envie de bosser et d'autre part
je suis pour qu'on on double le nombre
de parlementaires par exemple et moi je
souhaiterai que ma suppléante un
véritable rôle et que on puisse alterner
une semaine sur deux ou quelque chose
comme ça.
Bon est-ce que tu vois un sujet que tu
as oublié ?
Tu sais les sujets que j'oublie il y en
a il y en a plein. On a pas tellement
parlé de littérature.
Alors donne-nous trois bouquins.
Je sais pas
la peau et les eau de George Iverna
connais. Non, c'est un mec qui rentre du
Stalag en Allemagne, mais il a une
écriture qui est absolument superbe.
Euh la révolte des élites de Christopher
Lash qui est un intellectuel américain
des années 70 et qui montre comment il y
a une élite multiculturelle qui
s'installe dans un paquet de pays et
puis je sais pas trop. Bartleby de
de Melville,
un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui va rester sur les
réseaux.
regardant la caméra là. Mais je c'est
c'est le regard flottant de celui qui
réfléchit. Non, je je juste c'est je me
souviens de qui j'étais.
Je je me souviens de qui j'étais quand
j'étais jeune et que j'étais bien plus
abattu, bien plus découragé, bien plus
résigné que les gens que j'ai décrité au
cours de cette émission. Euh mais en
même temps, je grouillais d'une révolte,
mais d'une révolte
d'un désir d'expression de mais dont je
voyais pas de possibilité de d'un canal,
tu vois. Je voyais pas ce que je pouvais
faire de ma vie. Je voyais, j'avais
l'impression que euh bah il y avait des
tas de gens qui étaient éduqués, qui
savaient lire et écrire et que donc bah
j'allais juste être un de plus parmi 60
millions et que donc bah ça motait euh
tout de toute audace, tu vois, et euh
que finalement à partir de comment du
moment où on commence à essayer quelque
chose et ben il y a des fois où ça
marche, il y a des fois où ça marche pas
mais même quand ça marche pas ensuite on
invente autre chose. Donc c'est juste
quand je passe dans les fac ou dans les
lycées, je dis aux jeunes si vous avez
envie de faire un truc, juste faites-le
quoi, tu vois, c'est tout. Et
évidemment, j'aurais pas pensé devenir
député, écrire des bouquins, enfin,
j'aurais bien voulu écrire des bouquins
quand même déjà, faire un film, obtenir
un César et tout ça. Juste, j'avais
envie de faire un journal et et j'ai eu
du mal, tu vois. Mais je l'ai fait et
juste voilà si c'est juste qu'il y a pas
un truc qui pourrisse euh
un désir qui pourrisse à l'intérieur des
jeunes et euh dont ils sentent que ils
auraient pu le faire fleurir et queils
l'ont pas fait. Il faut le faire
fleurir, il faut essayer, tu vois. Et
puis après ça marche ou ça marche pas,
c'est la vie. Mais il faut essayer. Puis
en plus, je crois que même quand ça
marche pas, on finit toujours par en
faire quelque chose de positif, quoi. Tu
sais, un bébé pour apprendre à marcher,
il faut qu'il se casse la gueule et
pareil des milliers de fois. Tu imagines
s'il avait honte et qu'il disait
"Putain, je vais me casser la gueule."
Donc je vais pas essayer. Ben il
apprendrait jamais à marcher. Bah nous
c'est pareil. Il faut qu'on apprenne et
qu'on accepte de se casser la gueule
pour pour grandir quoi.
François Ufin. Merci.
Merci à vous.
Coupz.
[Musique]